when did you realize you had artistic
talent
oh boy i think the first drawing that i
can remember doing
was in kindergarten and i think that the
teacher just said
you know draw something that you like
and
even back then i was obsessed with
alligators
as i'm still today obsessed with
alligators but um
uh i i can remember drawing a
an alligator with you know green crayons
whatever and
um i don't remember what it looked like
exactly
but i do remember that people made a
fuss about it
like hey wow that's a really good
drawing
and i didn't really think that much of
it um
until it kept happening people kept like
like i
i'd win a prize for my drawing like
in second grade or whatever and and then
people
started to say oh you know frankie's
going to be an artist when he grows up
ring's going to be an artist
like okay i'm going to be an artist when
i grow up until i hit that stage
that teenage years where i was like you
can't tell me what i'm going to be
i'm not going to be an artist i'm going
to be an actor you know whatever
but uh but early that early on like
however old you are in kindergarten
four or five something like that all
right who did you want to
emulate as an actor oh boy i wanted to
be
uh at different stages i wanted to be
david hedersen who was the star of
voyage to the bottom of
of the sea and the movie the lost world
from 1960 erwin allen's version of the
lost world
and i wanted to be david hedison because
he got to do all these cool things
he got to fight dinosaurs and he had to
you know fight a giant spider and he did
you know he saved the girl and all that
kind of stuff and then
uh and so the in the 1960s there were a
lot of movies like ray harryhausen
movies where there was a
you know good-looking hero who would
fight monsters
and that was so appealing to music james
franciscus was another one that i was
like i'm
i'm going to be james franciscus without
you know
and fight fight tyrannosaurus rex's in
in the middle of the desert
but uh uh you know i i every so every
every few years i would find another
actor that i sort of glammed on to and
was like that's who i'm gonna be you
know
like george siegel for many years i that
was in like
high early high school i i just loved
george siegel and so
he wore a lot of these irish sweat uh
sweaters
right so i i wore those all the time my
i had my hair
styled the way he did and everything
like that but uh yeah i i was
easily influenced by my heroes
where did you get the sweaters lip
growing up and was it upstate new york
or oh they weren't they were just
knockoffs they weren't the real irish
sweaters but they looked like the ones
that george wore
so that was good enough sorry you did
you grew up in
long island all right not yeah i grew up
um i grew up on
long island um which is off of new york
um uh the north shore of long island
which is
part of the reason i don't have the long
island accent
um but that's also from comes from i
think
acting training as well i think you you
try to lose any any distinguishable act
accent when you're
you're planning to do to be an actor
because you don't want to be pigeonholed
and as someone who
who's only from this particular area
whatever um unless you're going to go on
the sopranos and then
you know then it works but in your favor
obviously i was going to say yeah a lot
of shows now it might actually work in
your favor
even if you're not from the east coast
although i mean if you look at you look
at the walking dead
half of that cast are from britain
uh you mean you know the governor and
and rick grimes the the lead like
they're they're
uh they're all from from england so but
apparently apparently
southern is the easiest accent to learn
if you're if you're from there
oh interesting that's what they tell me
how would you spend your time as a kid
drawing
yeah um drawing
my own comic books um drawing monsters
so one probably the very first movie
that i ever saw
when i was maybe six oh this is at least
that i can remember
this one stuck in my head i was on my
grandmother's house and you know this
gigantic tv
right black and white tv and abbott and
costello me frankenstein
oh wow goes on and i had never seen
anything like that before
i was blown away by it just the wolf man
and dracula and frankenstein and
i don't think i even saw it as a comedy
at
that age you know i saw it that these
monsters fascinated me
leave it and from that point on
mostly true were monsters so i would
draw the wolf man original frankenstein
anything
at all and then aurora was a model kit
company in the 1960s and they
uh they came out with these monster
models
and that became an obsession also is
building these models and painting them
and everything like that but it was
always it was monsters i just love
monsters
and then even as a teenager were you not
so you didn't sort of want to become the
next paul mccartney you
you wanted to draw or be an actor yeah
what music
and yeah i don't think that i was
particularly skilled in
social cases and this is very common
with uh what we've discovered with kids
that
that uh what we call monster kids now
kids who kids who are obsessed with you
know the old classic monster movies and
so forth is that
um especially back in the 60s and you
know early
70s there was no internet there was a
you couldn't even
you know you didn't even have vhs or
anything like that so when these movies
came
on television it was an event you know
you go you go
every week run down to get the tv guide
and flip through and try to see if like
if there are any cool monster movies
showing that week right
but we there weren't there were usually
only one or two
kids in your school that had the similar
interest
and so uh it could be a you know kind of
a
lonely existence actually um at least at
least
because of your interest um
that you'd spend a lot of time by
yourself
um if you were lucky there was another
kid that you know you befriended who
also loved that stuff and then you
you guys could draw together
or or make you know little super eight
movies which a lot of us did also
um but um i i think that um
i think spent a good deal of the time
drawing and um and and
creating is really maybe a better way to
put it because it wasn't just drawing it
was
sculpting things in clay and and
writing up stories uh you know writing
writing
scripts that we never would make but we
we pictured making them quite a lot
i think that's probably common for a lot
of movie fans movie
nerds whatever back in the day too maybe
except for now with the dslrs it seems
like everybody is doing it but
back in the day you sort of found refuge
in these movies and it was like a safe
place and
and those who didn't fit in you know
myself included it was
it was this is these were my people
right here you know and i felt
good and and kind of you feel safe
amongst the the crowd in the movie
theater or watching it on tv yeah and
when
it got to the uh the early 70s
uh the coolest thing happened which was
they started doing
sci-fi conventions uh in new york star
trek
conventions and and i wasn't like a
trekkie or whatever you want to call
them i
wasn't um i wasn't obsessed with star
trek
but i liked it a lot and the star trek
conventions would be more than just star
trek it would be science fiction in
general so there would be
peop there would be guys selling movie
posters and and stills and slides and
all kinds of stuff
that um that i started to collect
uh to just basically plaster the walls
of my room with
yeah so but that also opened up the door
to
other people that were not in my town
who had similar interests so you might
actually start a friendship
you know pen pals we called them vacuum
yeah where you're now
writing to people that don't live in
your town and comparing notes about
movies and so forth oh did you see
conquest of the planet of the apes yeah
you know talk about it
sure it's great yeah i found horror
conventions
some of the nicest people oh yeah and
you wouldn't you'd so it's like you know
and they're like
you know they look like marilyn manson
or something and they're actually
the kindest people where you go to the
opera and
not so much they're the real monsters
maybe i don't know
growing up in new york you said you grew
up in
long island but in the which shore north
shore okay
did you dream about coming to hollywood
i definitely dreamt of coming to
hollywood
um i didn't know what it looked like
i didn't know what the reality of it was
anything like that
um uh i just you know what you saw
on how how television portrayed
hollywood is what i thought hollywood
was
like you know the movie studio you got a
guy walking this way in a
in a suit of armor and a guy walking
this way in a bunny suit you know and
they're like hey how are you you know
um uh i did not know the uh the amount
of work
involved uh to get there um and the
uh the patience and the thick skin you
needed and all those kind of things but
you know like like a lot a lot of kids
just you had a picture of what it was
like and you're going to go there and
make movies and
and be james franciscus fighting a
dinosaur or whatever and
and so definitely dreamed of it
and so when i would make my own little
super eight movies
i would almost always be the star of it
you know
um be able to i could find a dinosaur in
my super eight movie at least
right um but it was so far away
from where i lived you know i and if you
grow up here and you see movies being
made all the time down the street you
know you run into
you can run into movie stars at the
grocery store et cetera
but where i was living there were a
couple of movie stars who lived out at
the
tip of long island in an area called
sands point that was
rather lucrative um
but that actually leads me to to my
first brush
with real hollywood uh i was
18 i think at that point um
and again i didn't really have at that
point i hadn't really
thought about like going to hollywood
and be working on movies
it was a nice dream but i hadn't wasn't
going to pursue it any further than that
and
my friend scott his parents
um owned nina's shoes which is a huge
shoe company
back then i don't know if it's still
around or not but they had this mansion
in sands point this very you know
exclusive area and he called me up one
day and he said
uh hey listen they're shooting a movie
at my parents house you want to come
over and like check it out
well like yeah sure i didn't know what
the movie was
and i get there and right off the bat i
had my first experience of what it's
like to be on a set because
i got out of my car and i went up to
somebody i went to say hey do you know
where scott and they turn around
okay and i didn't realize that like you
really have to be quiet you know not
just quiet you have to be
quiet right so that was my first lesson
right so
i go around to the back and i find scott
and a couple of my other friends were
there
and they're shooting a scene
in the the back part of the house and
i look over and there's robert de niro
and jerry lewis and martin scorsese is
sitting behind the camera
they were shooting the king of comedy
there a
big scene actually in the film and
i didn't know the plot obviously i think
they made scott maybe filled me in a
little bit of what it was but
i this was this blew my mind i was like
oh my god
like and then i'm looking around and
seeing
everything that's going into it all the
trucks and the generators and the lights
and the
cameras and the you know the people
doing all these different things
you know and um i was
i was just it really just blew my mind
um i i i felt like it was a dream
you know and at one point they broke for
lunch and
everybody so the whole set sort of
cleared away and i i walked in there by
myself
and there's this living room and it was
set up with
uh with pictures of jerry lewis with
different people this was supposed to be
his house right and
and i saw and i and i saw the sign that
said
do not touch hot set and i was thinking
that it meant that it was physically i
was going to burn my hand if i put my
hand on anything
and find out later it just means you
know that it's a working
set so you can't you can't move anything
or touch anything
but uh it was an amazing experience and
i then i definitely said
okay this is a real thing
this is this is something that you can
do
how you get there i'll i'll figure that
out somehow you know
but uh i it was it was eye-opening
do you go back and watch that scene i
just watched it
maybe a couple of months ago again and
yeah and watching that scene in
particular
uh well i just thought the memories just
come flooding back and thinking like wow
this was this was a key moment
like probably probably i didn't cost
ellenbe frankenstein was the first one
king of comedy was the second one for
sure
when you moved out to hollywood from new
york did you have a job lined up did you
have friends that were able to help you
get in the business no i
dragged my wife leanne kicking and
screaming
to la and i went because i had
at that point made the four horror
movies in in
up in canada with john fasano and
um but and then i was fully bitten by
the bug
at that point i mean i knew i was going
to keep doing this
whatever it was whether it was acting or
if it was i
discovered that i liked writing during
the course of making those those films
so
now john he
if you pardon the expression john had
brass balls
because he just picked uh he wrote a
script and he picked up and he went to
la
and he sold a script like six figures
right off the bat to morgan creek oh wow
right
and it was like holy crap like
he did it like he came out here and they
never made that movie by the way but
it did lead to him then writing another
48 hours and
um uh uh was the other
he wrote many drafts of alien three um
he wrote a whole bunch of movies
um so i thought well john did it
i can do it and at the time i was
working
i was working in the south tower of the
world trade center
oh yeah and i quit that job
and said leanne i have to go i have to
go to la
and she did not want to go but she did
and we got out here and there our first
place was this
uh you know renovated garage it was just
it was just awful and i i i
i had pictures you know i had my head
shots and and i had two scripts with me
that i had written and then when i got
out here i discovered how difficult it
was
to get somebody to read your scripts and
also
to get a part i mean you know as an
actor
you're i mean that's that would have
been true in new york as well but but i
think even more so out here is that you
know there are
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people who all want that part
and uh you know if you so there's a lot
of rejection
what year was this sorry this is this
was 1990
1990 okay okay yeah so pre pre-aol
oh yeah no no one was dialing up really
unless you were some
no and i'm in here somewhere yeah i mean
i made the rookie mistake
and a lot of a lot of aspiring
screenwriters do this
but i'm i fess up i did it too i
took my script i took the script i
thought was the best one
and i made copies of them i put them in
envelopes and i sent them to every
agency in town and one by one they
all came back unopened with a stamp on
it that basically said we
cannot accept unsolicited material uh
because it is a legal liability
so all these scripts came back to me it
was like i was so
ugh it was just i started to wonder like
did i make a mistake to move out here
and i was getting little jobs as i
worked as a pa on
a couple of movies and did some extra
work and so forth and
and and leanne started to get work um as
a casting uh associate
and she she so she worked on some good
some cool shows and some good movies
she worked with victoria burroughs who's
like one of the biggest
casting directors in town and um
so but but you know we were struggling
without a doubt
and uh i was really starting to wonder
have i made a big mistake here that i
might drag my poor wife out here and
it's not working
yeah and john john was doing great but
he couldn't really help me
um there was only so much he could do
why do you think he couldn't because
there's that misconception of like oh
they won't
help me or you know you you don't want
me you know
is can there can you dispel how maybe it
really works i think with
well with john i i think john would
would have been happy to help but he had
already reached this level
up here and it it's kind of hard to
bring somebody
in at that level i mean he was great i
mean he
brought me to the set of another 48
hours and i had lunch with walter hill
and nick nolte and everything like that
it was
it was cool everything like that and um
we did make a
movie um a a feature-length
movie on super eight sound that john
actually
paid for um he gave us like ten thousand
dollars i think
and uh we we made an entire movie
super eight sound it's never been
released because it's
super h sound you can't can't get um
a real release of it um but but the
script was really good
and and i got you know some good act i
directed it and
got some really good actors to be in it
you know for for free
and um and john paid for it he never
came to the set
he just he just gave us the money and
and go for it
and was happy with it at the end
although one thing that is funny is
that like like so often
happens with independent horror movies
uh when the movie was finished and
showed it to john he came back and he
said you need to do some reshoots i need
more nudity and no more blood
and we did we'd say we did so you
re-shot yeah we just we just did some
pickup we shot a a whole new um title
sequence that
had a lot of a lot of a lot of topless
women and
uh and tarantulas crawling on
so that was crazy no particular order
yeah no it was just sort of this
visionary kind of thing right
um well speaking of independent horror
you were in the 1988
horror film is it black roses and its
premises like this heavy metal band
comes to this conservative town
and warps all the teenagers minds yeah
so you had been through you had already
experienced something like that where
oh sure they needed to sort of up the
the the viewability exactly the the
investors for
for that movie um and i think maybe even
for rock and roll nightmare one of the
other movies we had done
up in canada um we came back and it was
like yeah we need more
more naked women and and more monsters
or more gore
or whatever just to just pump it up and
be able to sell it on a market
in the 1980s that was basically that's
what horror movies were
sure sure no they were there that was
the time of the friday the 13th movies
and so forth so
you know sex and blood and rock and roll
were all
you know things that uh you needed yet
it was taking off the boxes
yeah you know that's why people went to
the movies yeah exactly
um so um but yeah
john john could only do so much
basically and i understood that
you know i and i did not expect you know
to come out here and have him
you know hold my hand and and thr and
give me things for
you know for free or whatever freeze and
what i mean but
you know he introduced me to charlton
heston that was that was enough for me
yeah that's well most yeah because
people don't get that
yeah absolutely no that was a big thrill
because i was like
yeah i still am i'm glad that john
wasn't able
to um help me
that much you know um aside from
introducing me to some people and so
forth and
making that little movie that we called
spider bite the super 8 sound movie
um because i think that um i think you
have to earn it
yourself i mean i i believe that
uh these days it's really it's a lot
easier to
sort of work your way into the business
because
you know you can you can buy a credit
you can
you know what i mean like you can you
can go to a kickstarter campaign and
they're making a movie and you can
buy a credit you can buy you can buy uh
an associate producer credit or whatever
you know what i mean
and build up your resume that way you
know we didn't have that i don't
i don't blame anybody for doing that but
i'm saying that we never had that luxury
we everything that we had to do we had
to really do it ourselves
earn it uh to work our way up up the
ladder
if you want to call it the ladder you
know to to achieve what we wanted to
achieve
do you ever not correct someone but give
them
maybe big brother advice on
that same mindset because i think it
even though
social media is great because you can
speak to so many people and if you're
active in one cause you might end up
tweeting a celebrity or something
or or somebody of of note that could
maybe
help you but there's still that idea
where i can still
like just i can access all this and just
jump over
all the hurdles do you ever like dispel
that myth for
for people yeah i if i ask i do um
people don't always listen but you do
say something
yeah i do i do and what do you say i've
said i've said i have a friend
recently that i said said it too i said
you know
um i i think these these are mistakes
these are your mistakes to
to to make you know what i mean like
like
i can tell you something and you can
listen to me or you cannot listen to me
whatever either way you're gonna you're
gonna
you're gonna make you're going to make
your own mistakes
basically is what i meant and and
sometimes that's a good thing it's how
you learn
sure but even coming here in 1990 there
was no youtube
you couldn't do a web series you
couldn't do a kickstarter indiegogo or
sedan spark
you had to really have someone endorse
you it was just a
totally different ball game then oh sure
and and in fact
getting an agent which has forever been
the the catch-22 you know you can't um
you can't get a uh you can't get a movie
unless you have an agent
but you know you can't get an agent
unless you've had a movie
uh uh you know that's as old as the
hills um
and it's still kind of true um the only
difference is now
because of platforms like youtube and so
forth where people can
show off their creativity and it's it's
a lot easier to get it seen
and we made that little spider bite
movie with the hopes that we could show
it to
you know people and get them interested
in in
you know either the actors or myself as
a writer or as a director or whatever
um it was something that we could show
and that's
you know that's what you that's that's
all you could do back then
uh is have something to show and the
trick was
how do you get it to them you then like
nowadays
put it on your website put it on youtube
put it you know wherever and
um you can just direct people toward it
which is great
i'm not knocking it at all no no you
know back then it was um
i sound like like an old geezer back
then we had to walk through
50 miles of snow um well the 90s wasn't
that long ago and
in terms of to some technology i mean
i realized yes you know data was the new
thing that was coming you know it was
going to be so great
yeah and you know i remember my first
computer which was
you know uh i think my first computer
was probably
right before i moved out here but
then aol came along and then all of a
sudden now uh
uh you know you're you're talking to to
lots of people
not just the ones that you might meet at
a party or the kids you grew up with or
whatever like now it's
it's huge um i
i a lot of my friends that i still hold
dearly today are are people that i i met
talking about monsters on the internet
and comparing notes about like how
how miserable is it that we can't get
anyone to look at our scripts
did you think about driving back home i
did
um i definitely did especially when um
i couldn't get anyone to look at look at
the scripts right
and so this is an interesting story
so uh my wife was doing some casting
work
at um a production company called
kushner lock
which i don't think they're in business
anymore but they were down in santa
monica
and um we only had one car so every
morning i would drive her down there
from from north hollywood and drive back
and then at the end of the day drive
back down again and so i was basically
spending six hours
six hours in the car every single day
and um
but she was working there um on casting
um
i think it was like the hbo show first
and ten i think which is why i think
their first
hbo's first series right i think it had
oj in it actually
um and uh uh but there were other
offices there
on that floor of the kushner lock floor
and and sometimes i would go there i was
trying i was writing spec scripts for
the show that they were producing called
sweating bullets and um i was showing
them to
um uh to uh who was it peter locke i
think
was was the lock of kushner luck
and um uh you know there was always
something wrong with them one way or
another like i
wrote one that was had voodoo element to
it and
right off the bat he just he's like oh
we're not allowed to you know that the
the network doesn't want any voodoo
like oh great right so but anyway
because he said that writing was was was
okay
it was just the more often it was the um
the subject material that he couldn't
work with but anyway
so one day i was there and leanne goes
oh i want you to meet
um a really cool guy he takes me on the
hallway this little office and inside is
this
this gentleman and she says bill i want
you
this is my husband frank and he says hi
uh william asher
and i realize who it is and um for those
who don't know william asher is a
was a legendary producer director he
um he directed almost all the episodes
of i love lucy
he wrote the um he created the um the
show bewitched with his wife
at the time elizabeth montgomery uh he
he
directed all those beach blanket movies
with frankie and annette and so forth so
i mean the man
really was a legend and there i am now
talking to him and he was
a lovely man and i sat down with him
and we started you know just chatting
and i started telling my
tale of woe that i couldn't get anybody
to read my scripts
so he goes um i'll read your scripts
like oh cool all right right and uh
so he took them and a few days later
um i was back there again and he called
me in his office and sat me down and he
said he goes
okay so he said so this one he goes uh
he goes it was it's okay it was
the writing's okay he goes it but it has
a supernatural element and i spent 10
years producing a show about magic so
i'm kind of like done with that so
it was that part of it he didn't care
for it but he said but this one
he said this one this is great goes this
is a great script because he did a great
job
characters are good the story works it's
really good he said
don't give up he said
don't don't move back to new york or
whatever he goes if this is a real
sample of what you can do you will get
an agent
you will you will get work right
and that was so inspiring to me i was
just like that was that was the
encouragement that i
needed right at that moment to come from
somebody of
of his pedigree right super nice man
so um so i didn't leave stayed
and he was right within four four or
five months
from then i got my first agent i had my
first movie sale
very shortly after that oh wow had made
about i wrote i got hired to write a lot
of scripts but
um maybe five of them got made but
that's still good
that's still a very good ratio
um so but here's where the story gets
very interesting okay
we're gonna flash forward now like 20
years
right a few just a couple of years ago
my um my co-writer and producing partner
todd trina and i meet
go to meet um uh at you know chateau
marmont for
right and uh
you know which is your table by the way
and um we were meeting about another
project
entirely but as we're leaving todd says
oh um we have um we actually have some
movement on
i hate kids which was a script that he
and i had co-written
and i'm like oh cool like so what's
going on he goes he goes well we have an
investor we've already got like a you
know
some like a million dollars you know
invested
he goes i'm going to be working on
getting more and he says and we have a
director
i'm like really who who was that he said
his name is john asher
i just went john mallory asher
and he goes oh i don't know his middle
name i was like was he a child actor was
he on weird science
he was like i don't know and
i realize of course this
is the son of the man who encouraged me
to stay
20 years earlier how interesting and
john
asher i met with john asher and uh and
told him that story and he flipped out
he was like holy cow um
he couldn't believe it and but i knew it
right at that moment
that that movie was going to get made
because that
that kind of synchronicity is just you
can't
you can't deny it you know i mean like
and uh
and the movie was made yeah and we want
to talk about
more and you're in your partnership with
todd a little bit but i just was curious
with the first script that you sold how
many scripts do you think you had
actually
written before whether they were in a
drawer or whatever
before you actually um sold one
ah feature probably not many
not many um i had i had the two that i
that it came out here with
um and those are full lengths yeah
they're featured they were features
um and probably maybe just
two or three more um before um
now my my my agent or manager
uh at that time had read the one that
that
that um william ascher had said was good
and based on that she took me on as a
client
on that script that you know that's and
of course that movie's never been made
but every but everything that i've uh
the success i've had ever since then is
because
of that script right yeah and and
just briefly what was the script that
you actually sold like what what did it
entail oh it was um
uh it was called return of the gargoyle
and
because um because i was friends with
adam west because we had made
zombie nightmare together um and
the uh the the michael keaton uh
batman movie had recently come out or
not that long ago but but you know this
new improved
version of batman with these muscles and
all this stuff right
had come out and so i i came up with
this this funny idea that um
uh the story would be about a guy who
used to play a superhero
on tv who was now sort of washed up and
was divorced from his wife
and miserable and and this new version
of his old character comes out
and now he's really feeling awful and uh
he one night he he's ready to jump off a
bridge when he suddenly hears somebody
being mugged
and he runs into the alley and he saves
this person
and he snaps basically he starts so he
starts putting on his old costume
and going out and trying to fight crime
for real
and you know he gets kicked out of
him
and you know and uh and all these other
things happen but
um there's a detective who's trying to
figure out who who he is and all that
kind of stuff so
it was it was really it was a little bit
of a love letter to adam
and um but it was my it was it was the
first comedy
that i had written um the other ones
before that were
more um um more sci-fi-ish
kind of stuff and uh you know die hard
in a
zoo or something like that i don't know
i mean everybody was writing a die-hard
movie back then
um but um uh
but everybody who read that script
really enjoyed it and i would
so i would get work from that script
even though that script
uh was never made the vigilante
superhero oh interesting
yeah adam adam read it um i gave it to
adam and his adam's
agent um and uh they they loved it
uh and adam was willing to you know he
was like well if you can get a
modest budget you know he goes i'd love
to do it to be fun but you know that
wasn't that wasn't meant to be
so if you knew that it would have taken
you that long to sell one
do you think you would have still come
out because you you saw your friend john
who
was just like you know he got these
green lights and angels were singing for
him
and you know and and so you thought well
then i can do this too
do you think you would have still stayed
back in new york
i hope not because
if i had not left that job
at the world trade center things would
be very different sure um
but um i you know what i was
i was so bitten by the bug probably
probably still would have done it yeah
yeah i think so
what's the closest you've come to moving
back home
probably just earl very early on
um i'm there are parts of new york i
certainly miss
uh i still have some family there and
and i love
seasons um but um
i really haven't looked back since
things started to
you know go my way i have a quote here
um i always have to have one quote in
every interview
always ask yourself is this going to
help me get to my goal or not
and i believe that's from bob proctor
do you do you have a certain set of
guidelines you you work
from like it's is there a quote is there
a mantra is there something that guides
you
do you do you subscribe to this you know
do you look at something and say
am i doing this for the right reasons am
i doing this for fun
is this going to help me get to my goal
you know i think
earlier on i was much quicker to just
take
whatever came along or
to work for exposure
and work on spec and um
because i needed to
you know build up a reputation of some
kind
as far as a mantra though um
i don't know i mean i i i know that
i can i can listen to the pitch of a
of an idea that if someone is looking to
hire me
right i can hear what their basic idea
is and i will know
almost immediate almost immediately if
i'm the right person for that
job um
i i can i can
sometimes i've broken my own rules but
everybody breaks their own rules every
once in a while um
but usually because what will usually
happen is that um
uh all my my agent
would send me in i'd sit down with
the producer or um who the director and
they might already have a script they
might not um
they might just have an idea but i can i
can usually tell very quickly
um if if i'm going to be able to bring
anything to this project
if i'm going to be able to make it what
it is they want it to be
um so uh and usually
what's very funny is usually if i
don't think i don't say it right away
right i don't tell them that that
whether or not i think i'm the right
person not right away
but most of the time if i don't think
i'm the right person i don't get the gig
anyway
so
i i don't know if i have like any kind
of
quote or something that sticks with me
um uh
aside from from william asher saying
don't give up
and you can still see his face oh sure
yeah wow that's a really
really interesting story just the whole
chain and
the sun and that's really fascinating
yeah and then it was
what was funny also about that is that
um our first meeting when i first met
his son john and the and the producers
of aihi kids around the table
and they're all talking and everything
like that and somebody mentions john
landis
and i admit i knew john because he was
in my first
the first documentary on it and i'm like
why
what about john landis and i go oh he's
the executive producer of this movie
oh my god okay this movie is definitely
getting made
sure and that was your king kong
documentary or
no john was uh john was in beast wishes
the first one about bob and kathy burns
yeah so you've come out to la armed with
scripts
and are you also auditioning too
yes and you know you have this other
talent which is to draw
um how soon before you say well i'm
going to
try to utilize that to make a living and
and
fulfill my artistic well here's the
thing
i always believe that when an
opportunity arises
take it um and what happened was i
i mentioned earlier that that my wife
leanne was
was in casting and um
she had gotten a job at walt disney
feature animation
in the casting department i think they
were i think they were working on
hunchback um at the time
and um and she had been there for a few
months and
and she was really liking working there
and
just by being there she just met the
people in the animation department and
the producers of the animated shows and
so forth and she got to see
basically how things work there and she
she i remember her calling me up
from work one day and saying you know
you could do this
like you could definitely do this and i
was like well i guess but you know i'm
not i don't know anything about
animation i didn't
except for animating little clay figures
you know for super eight movies um
but she she said well you should you
should you know find out
because you could get a job here like
they're looking for people because
you know um uh jeffrey katzenberg had
was just opening up um uh dreamwork down
the street
and was grabbing up lots of animators
you know and poaching them from disney
to you know to stock up
you know his his studio so everybody was
looking for animators so i was like okay
well i'll
i'll go and take a class i guess
i went to the animation um union and
so i started taking classes there in a
hurry
i was taking as many as i could right
and
even though because because even though
i was act i was
working i was a working screenwriter you
know
a working screenwriter can not work for
a year sometimes
right and so it was
feaster famine most of the time and i'm
i was still i was
when i sold the script it was really
good money but then it might be
a long time before i sold another one i
mean at least at least one that got made
um you know you get paid something for
for writing it but you get a lot of
money if the movie gets made
for that we call the first day of
principal check which is
really nice um so
i thought well wouldn't it be nice
though to because i'd now i'd been
writing for
you know a few years wouldn't it be nice
to have like an actual
steady job steady paycheck for a while
so so i went and i learned i learned
about animation really fast
i took all these classes these uh i
learned
how to what kind of a portfolio to
submit
um because uh that's that's that's where
a lot of people go wrong
uh when when trying to get a job back
then at least uh trying to get a job in
animation is that
they would turn in a portfolio filled
with drawings of mickey mouse and goofy
and that was the last thing that uh
disney animation wanted to see they
wanted to see that you could
draw that you could draw human figures
that you could do life drawing gesture
drawing
you know real artwork not just traced
cartoons
right so so i did i put together a
portfolio and i submitted it and i
and i got in so that was good
it was in fact it was great i started
working on hercules like almost
immediately
that was the good side the bad side was
i had to tell my manager
that i could not do any i couldn't take
any writing gigs
because once you're under the umbrella
of a corporation like that
the walt disney company is a very big
umbrella
they have you know they have music
departments and they have you know
obviously they make movies also and so
if you are a full-time employee and this
is not just disney by the way this is
also studio students if you're under
their employee
you cannot work for a
you know competition so if you write
a script while you are working for them
technically they own it and
the kind of hoops that you have to go
through to get it cleared so that you
could take it somewhere else
is just it would take months right
so i couldn't i couldn't i couldn't be a
writer for hire
for anywhere anywhere else um they
didn't look
disney didn't look at me as a writer
they looked at me as an artist
but it didn't matter uh same thing you
know other artists i was working for who
who created their own music
disney owned it as long as it was
written
and and put out you know while working
for them
um and it's a way to protect themselves
i get it that's i
that did it didn't bother me but i think
my my manager at the time was not
very happy about it because because i
was i was
i was working i was bringing in you know
bringing in
she was getting me jobs so um so
that was the downside of it for sure but
i i loved it i i like
working on hercules it was the first one
and they were already
well into the production of hercules by
the time that i
got in there by the way also i i think i
was in my mid-30s
at the time right all the other people
who came in with me
in that group that of of trainees
they were all fresh out of uh cal arts
so they were all like you know 21 you
know whatever
i was like the old man of the group so
it was like it just it seemed kind of
weird but
i didn't care i was i was just so happy
to be working there and to
be working on that level
of entertainment you know a
big movie that's gonna everybody's gonna
see it
and um even you know even though i'm a
small part of a much bigger
team um you know i'd still be part of it
i could still look at scenes and go ah i
did that scene that's cool
yeah and so um so i stayed um
until the job became obsolete basically
how did it become obsolete because uh
because of pixar because the pixar
movies were
making a lot of money and the hand-drawn
movies
at disney were not living living up to
expectation
i think that the um the powers that be
kind of look equated
cg movies make money hand-drawn movies
don't and
that's that wasn't true but i'm from a
money-making point of view
i'm sure that's what they thought the
truth is
the the scripts weren't as good as the
ones that pixar was putting out
and it always starts with the script i
mean you could have made
finding nemo hand-drawn
and it would still be just as good
it would be the same movie it would just
look a little different
it would still be a fantastic movie you
know the lion king
would still be you know a terrific movie
if it was done hand-drawn oh
wait lion king was doing a hand-drawn um
i i was up there saying like well the
lion king would be just as good if you
did it in cg
i know it's making a lot of money i
haven't seen it yet though but you know
the point is that
sure it was it was it was just that this
the scripts
weren't catching the eye of
the public um it was either the wrong
demographic that they were looking at
because they were doing they were
experimenting a little bit
like movies like atlantis uh and
treasure planet
which were not you know disney princess
movies um
and i i admired the fact that they were
trying to branch out and see but
it those movies just did not
um live up to their potential and sorry
what year was this when they kind of
made this
shift when they decided well i started
on hercules in 1996.
so i had been screenwriting for
three or four years um before that
right but when disney decided to go away
from the countdown
so that happened
early 2000s um i think that the last
last movie i worked on was called home
on the range
and i think that that came out in 2003
i want to say somewhere around there so
it was it was
the early part of the 2000s that
somewhere
right around there they made the
decision that that home on the range
would be the last
um hand-drawn film how much talk
before had had it been years of build up
to that point
did you hear that in the air yes but not
a lot of years
i can really i mean i some of us could
see the writing on the wall
and others refuse to believe it um
i can remember saying to somebody
at one point maybe it was while we were
making tarzan and they were starting to
use they were really starting to utilize
um
cg elements into the 2d movies and
and of course the pixar movies were
already doing great
you know bugs life and so forth were
doing really well
and i remember saying to one of my
colleagues there i said you know
i think 10 years from now they're all
going to be cg
and i the person i was talking to and i
don't remember who it was but it was
just like no way
that's there's no way that's not
possible and um
it turns out i was wrong it it only took
five years
wow so it happened pretty pretty quickly
so i mean even by the last movie by home
on the range by that time you know we
had all been told
this was the last one um and it was
that was not a good time i mean that
last that last year
um was was morale was very low and um
uh you know it's kind of some of those
people
like i said you know these kids had come
straight out of cal arts right well they
you know they had just done that
recently but there were people who were
working at that company
for 40 years who never had
another kind of job yeah you know they
never even worked
fast food or whatever they came right
out of calarts you know because cal arts
was created to basically groom disney
artists
they they went right to work and they
were there their whole their whole
existence and and now all of a sudden
they're
you know they're in their 50s and and
their job is gone
and it's not like you could even go to
another studio all the studios were
doing it
so that was a you know it was a big
transition for a lot of people now
um i don't i don't blame disney at all i
mean i think it's
it's evolution um in a way i mean this
is this is
what happens with all kinds of art i
think
but uh i felt bad
for a lot of people who did not you know
know what to do
you know people buy expensive houses and
expensive cars and everything like that
when things are going great
and uh that's why when occasionally um
i i'll go back to my college um in new
york to
uh to just be a guest speaker and things
like that and talk to
people about animation or acting or
filmmaking and general screenwriting and
one of the things i always tell them is
um you know pursue your dreams for sure
but have a backup plan because you never
know when
the the rug can be pulled out from under
you like we never
imagined that i thought i was going to
work for disney forever
you know and then all of a sudden
it ended um and and i could have i could
have tried to learn
cg and disney was great in that regard
because
they actually offered us free classes to
to learn it
and i took advantage of that i i took
the classes and
learned the maya um cg program
but i couldn't i couldn't find the joy
in it
it's a big difference now nowadays it's
a it's easier because
now they have wacom tablets where you
can you can draw right on the screen
so it's your drawing again but back then
the difference between drawing that the
tactile difference between drawing with
a pencil
and moving a mouse and clicking a mouse
very very different things
and that wasn't for me
what did some of those people end up
doing i mean their whole identity was
disrupted this was who they were
yeah and a lot of people it's how they
define themselves
so suddenly you have to find
something new to do i mean i you know
look i saw people that i
knew that were pulling down you know
nice nice fat paychecks every week at
disney
who were then working at trader joe's
and there's nothing wrong with working
at trader joe's but
my point is that it was the
the difference in the the amount of
money that you're bringing in
is substantial and it's because
that's all they knew and there's if
there's there wasn't any animation work
anymore
what are you going to do you got to find
some other way to make money
and people did all kinds of things some
people moved away and i don't know what
they did and
um some people started uh working on
um doing storyboards
for live action movies and um
some of my friends who came in with me
in that training class um
uh ended up directing tv shows for
disney
and uh and writing for tv shows for
disney and so forth
so some of us found our way
right so so they offered you these free
classes
you used the is the program called maya
you said yeah
okay back then that was that was the the
main program that they used for cg back
then
and you just knew pretty much instantly
this is not going to be for me
not instantly it took it took a couple
of months
before i was just like
my brain isn't wired for that
um i might you know
that there's that
that tactile thing where you're holding
a pencil between your fingers
and you know the these it's running up
here and then running back down again
and i got nothing from moving that
mouse around there was nothing that
wasn't happening
and and i was just like well maybe um
maybe i can go back to screenwriting
and you know there were every once in a
while there would
be a special project that came up that
needed 2d
my wife helped produce a series of um
educational films that had timon and
pumbaa from the lion king
and they did those in 2d and i got to
work on those and
and every once in a while something pops
up i mean just last year um
uh i got hired to work on mary poppins
returns
and got to uh you know work on animating
the the penguins
that you know dance with lin-manuel
miranda and uh
um emily blind and that was really cool
that was really cool um because that
scene in the original movie with dick
van dyke was my favorite scene in the
whole movie so
so stuff does come up but it's obviously
it's
cg is is really
is the leading technology for doing
animation now
there's talk i hear rumors they disney
might go back to doing
some 2d movies they did do princess and
the bro and the frog
a few years after home on the range um
which i didn't work on the movie itself
i did work on
some of the sort of commercials for it
um
but uh but um i've heard
i hear these rumblings and you never
know if they're rumors if they're true
or not but they said that there
there might be some consideration of
returning to
to 2d for for certain projects for
certain movies
and then you gave your two weeks notice
or it wasn't a two weeks notice you were
you were given two weeks they gave
me they gave me like a two month notice
okay like a severance or something and
you then you got a call
so you knew this date was coming that
you would be out of a job
yeah and then they did it in waves as
as we got further along on home on the
range
they they would let a certain amount of
people go
and then you know a few months later a
certain amount of people go and so forth
i i i managed to hang on right to the
very end
and this is in 2006 no earlier
earlier i think it was i think it was
i think it was 2003 actually okay so the
economy is doing decent so it's not like
they're letting you go in 2009 right
and then as luck would have it your
phone rings yes
yeah right around that time i mean it
was like within a week
uh i out of the blue i get a call from
todd trina
um who i had worked with uh on a great
script
many years before um called woodstuck
that still hasn't never been made but it
was it was again
a script that helped me get other work
um
uh and i really liked todd um when we
were working on that back then
really we did we definitely got along
really well and everything like that and
and it just so happened that right
around the time the disney gig was
ending
todd called me up and said hey are you
available i have an idea for a script
i'd love you to work on
with me and i was like oh as a matter of
fact
your timing is perfect and so uh
so i i started working with todd on the
script
uh that we called um without a hitch
at that at that time which was todd
todd's a great idea guy he would come up
with a great concept
for a movie and then um we would we
would bash out ideas
you know over over drinks often
and uh and then and then basically he
would send me off to
to write a first draft and uh and then i
bring it back to him and we talk it all
over and we come up with new ideas and
and you know then work on a second draft
and so forth and so forth as
long as many drafts as it needs to um
before it's ready to
to to put out there
and todd has his own production company
or he's been a producer and
forgive me how did you two meet again um
basically
todd was uh was helping bankroll
a a small in very small
independent um group of uh
one filmmaker basically um and
this was the guy who had hired me to
write this script that that was called
woodstock
and so so i met todd through the
director
of um who the guy who was going to be
the director of woodstock
and um like i said we just i i liked him
immediately
so you stayed in touch he's in the san
francisco bay area he would know he was
still at that time he's up there now
his family is all up there but uh he was
he was actually living
living down here um and uh you know we'd
meet up occasionally and you know go out
and have a dinner or something like that
but
but then we started really working
together uh on on
this script that he had this idea for
and
uh it's a uh it was a
a long time uh uh we'd work on it for a
few months and and then
you know other things would happen and
then a year later we'd come back and
work on it again
and some fresh idea would show up or
something like that so
um and uh we just have a very good
working relationship
yeah and so you've known each other like
a good amount of time 10 plus years yeah
since since the early 90s
and so the one idea that he called you
about has now turned into
the movie that's already out which is i
hate kids i hate kids i think
it's okay without a hitch we had done
all kinds of
drafts on on uh on without a hitch
um and uh you know adding characters
changing characters changing endings
changing beginnings
you know everything um to to get it
what we felt was right
um and uh
we were i think we were
we were right on the verge like we knew
we were getting really close
and i said well maybe we need a fresh
title
to sort of you know just spark hit that
spark plug again right and um
originally the the lead character in i
in in with
without a hitch was uh nick was um
he was a guy who owned a big surfing
company like surfing clothes and clothes
and so forth right
and somehow it just i don't know it
wasn't
really gelling and i
said what if he was because he because
the character wasn't wasn't
didn't have a lot of humor to him and i
thought well
what if we gave him an occupation where
humor was part of his job and he said
what if he's a
what if he's a writer what if he's a guy
who writes funny books
i know observational humor kind of thing
and that really that that fire took off
without a doubt and uh i think we i
think we made him british for a while
too
we were like um uh who were we basing it
on
hugh a cute oh hugh grant you know
because because i remember that todd
loves about a boy that movie about a boy
so um
but but but the writing having the
character be a writer being a
being a a humorist definitely helped us
gel that character and uh
and so i thought well he doesn't we know
he doesn't like
children and and his he's marrying
someone who doesn't like children so why
wouldn't his book be called i hate kids
and that immediately became the the
title of the movie
so which we changed it from without a
hitch to i hate kids and
we knew the title was working because
every time we said it to somebody they
laughed
every single time we said what's the
name of the movie it's called i hate
kids and they would laugh
because everybody can appreciate that
one way or another you know what i mean
and uh and then
um we started showing it around or todd
did
i wasn't involved that part of it todd's
the
business end of things you know and um
and he showed it to the
the right people at one point who wanted
to were interested in making it how does
that work
when when someone has this idea did he
already write a rough draft of it
and then you started working on it i if
i remember correctly and i'd have to
check with todd if this is right
um i think that at the very beginning i
think that there was
at least it was either an outline or it
was
uh it was a written opening scene
which was a wedding was it was an actual
wedding
um where this this kid shows up and and
says that you know i'm your i'm your dad
i mean you're my dad
um and that throws the whole thing into
chaos
um and but it wasn't
it wasn't more than just i think a scene
just so we really had to then
really develop where it was going to go
um um we we picked we i mean todd
already imagined it was going to be a
kind of a road trip movie oh okay
so i mean the idea of it being that this
guy is about to get married
to a woman and they both the thing that
they share is neither of them are
interested in having children
so um at the uh originally it was the
wedding itself
in the in the final draft of the script
the shooting script we had it um the
wedding rehearsal
because that would put a a ticking bomb
uh on into the script automatically so
he's got to figure he's got to get this
problem figured out before the wedding
which is in three days
so um uh so this kid shows up says
you know you're my dad and uh he doesn't
believe him
of course at first but um this
he's the kid has brought along with him
this psychic
um the amazing fabular who
has determined that nick
is in fact this kid's uh father
and uh nick still doesn't believe it of
course
until um we have this very funny scene
that we worked out where
how how does the kid know for sure that
that's his dad
and i'm pretty sure i came up with this
um
because he's a celebrity of some sort
right
his barber has been selling locks of his
hair
on ebay so the kid buys
a lock of his hair on ebay and then
sends it to a dna lab with his own hair
and the test comes back positive right
so
but but the psychic is still claiming
you know that it was all his
his doing right so the three of them
then go on a road trip to try to find
the kid's mom
he doesn't know who his mom is uh
and at the time the kid is now 14
13 or 14 and at the time that nick
uh the kid was conceived nick was dating
a lot of women
so the idea is now he's got to figure
out which of these many women
is the mother of this kid and that so
that's what propels everything forward
um and uh i i remember that we came up
with the the psychic
very late in the game really and over
the course of you know
however many years it was 12 years or
something like that but
um because we we
just thought it would be funny to have a
psychic with a little tiny dog
that's going along with it because it
also it also made a triangle
for the three main characters to play
off of each other it wouldn't just be
the father and the son you've also got
this irritating
you know kind of flamboyant uh
uh psychic there to constantly be
you know insulting nick and and
being nice to the kid and the kid being
nice to both of them and
it set up this really cool uh dynamic
between the three of them
and so are you writing and then emailing
him notes
are you meeting in person like how does
this work when
both oh okay yeah yeah sometimes uh we
would get together and
i would todd todd used to love when i
would
uh basically perform what i had come up
with
you know he would he'd sit back with his
glass of wine you know i'd put mine down
and i would act out i would act out
these new ideas oh that's interesting
well
you know this is something also that i i
when i when i teach classes in
in screenwriting or whatever um uh
i one of the things i always try to
to make aspiring screenwriters
understand is
it isn't first of all it's not just
about you know
watching movies i hear a lot of people
well i watch a lot of movies so i know
that i know how movies work and it's
like well no you don't
watching movies is great and you should
do that but you got to do way more than
that
and it's not just i think it's more than
just
reading uh books about writing
i think it's much more than that because
you're dealing in a medium
that uh it's much it's way more than
just
um your words yeah you know you you have
actors who then have to say those words
so
i always recommend screenwriters take an
acting class
um i think my background in acting
i mean i was a theater major at college
so i did a lot of acting
a lot of stage work and then i did the
horror movies in canada
that has helped me write dialogue
because
i can tell as an actor if that's a line
that i'm going to be able to say
um i think that
it if you can understand how an actor
looks at
a line it'll help you write a better
line for that actor
can you give me some examples i like
that let's say it's the scene where the
kids showing up at the wedding
i'm sure you had different ways of him
kind of you know the whole like if
anyone here objects i think you told me
that yeah
so yeah but but were there other sort of
ways you were planning on doing it and
you acted it out and realized
yeah no they wouldn't say it like this
they would say like this yeah i well
what i do
is i try to assign
in my head a voice for each character
right now sometimes it'll be the voice
of an an actor that i
know right i mean not personally or just
you know i'm i've
seen movies with that actor so like when
i so we made hugh grant
at one point when we were making him
british i had hugh grant's voice in my
head so it was a lot easier to write
that dialogue
hearing it coming from his voice in here
you know
um and then the acting um the acting out
part of it is
um i i must have looked like a crazy
person
because derek one of the one of the
apartments that we lived in
back then um was on the third floor
of in in like toluca lake area
uh of this apartment building and there
was a little tiny
office at the top of it a little tiny
office and there was a
there was an access door to the roof
right
and back then i would stay i could stay
up all night
writing i i was just i was more of a
night owl back then not anymore not so
much anymore
but i would i'd come up with a scene or
it'd be close to getting a scene and
it'd be two o'clock in the morning and
i'd go outside out onto the roof
and i'd be walking around up there
talking to myself like acting out the
part
and yeah and and trying to come up with
the dialogue that would be true to the
character
and not be too expositional which is
something that
all of us screenwriters must avoid
uh and and see if it worked see if it
worked just
at least you know out loud or or in my
head
and that's what i would finally
um commit to
sometimes the character would change
voices um
if it wasn't working um my for for the
amazing fabular um i was telling you
earlier that
he was you know the psychic in my head
as i was writing it
it was um jonathan harris um
who was dr smith on lost in space the
old tv series
and he was very flamboyant and so both
you know
and uh and that was the voice in my head
but when um
when we went to make the movie and
and titus burgess got the role
um he didn't want to play it like that
because that he felt like that was too
close to a character that he plays on
the unbreakable can be schmidt
so he wanted to downplay him a little
more you know and it so
i remember the first couple of days on
set i was very lucky by the way
that john asher allowed me to be on set
every day
oh that's great um and and consulted
with me from time to time
um he always had the final word of
course because he's the director it's
not my movie anymore it's his you know
but um
um titus um did not want to play
i just didn't want to play him the way i
had written it or at least how the voice
in my head
had written it and so it took a couple
of days for me to get used to
and in the end it worked out fine um but
those first couple of days i was just
like oh shouldn't i
ash pulled asher aside and it's just
like like sneaky bigger and everything
like that and
um but i i think it also those first
couple of days were that were difficult
for titus because
literally day one first day day one
that morning the emmy nominations were
announced and he was nominated which
means that
that whole day he was getting his phone
must have been just blowing up from his
all of his agents and his managers and
his friends and his family all
calling him and you know saying
congratulations anything like that so i
think he was a little
a little distracted this first first day
or so but um
but uh you know in the end it's it's a
he gave a great performance and i'm
you know very very happy um
that that he was involved and he played
played the role how was that to be on
set
in terms of hearing your words
repeated back and knowing that it's not
really your baby anymore
but you're still there you still have a
tiny bit of say maybe
and most screenwriters aren't really
allowed on set or maybe are they
is this was this a rare thing it depends
um
this is the first this was the first
movie where i
i had complete access so
i i was allowed there every single day
um uh the first movie that i had made
um it was a movie called naked souls
which was a sci-fi movie and uh
they they let me like they didn't stop
me from coming
but i didn't feel like i because it was
it was the first one it was the first
movie that of mine that was getting made
um i i i didn't feel comfortable like
showing up there every day
there wasn't a chair with your name on
no absolutely not absolutely not
i have one of those now though
but you were allowed to pop in i was and
but like other times though i mean
um uh there were these two children's
movies i wrote for paramount
that um i had to write i had to write
them both in two weeks
um because they the scripts that they
had
they were already too far into the
production so they already had costumes
made and everything like that and they
were but they were shooting it in prague
and these scripts just weren't working
and so they basically they hired me
to write two scripts the first one and
the sequel they were going to shoot back
to back
in two weeks so the first week i wrote
the first one
second week i wrote the second one sent
them off to prague
and never saw any footage of it until
the movies came out on
vhs so for this one you were allowed on
set
yeah and you felt like you were welcome
which which is probably a very rare
thing yeah well i mean it helped that
todd trainer um you know was one of the
producers
sure um uh and and i think that you know
john asher was so
uh surprised and delighted that
i knew his dad that he he
you know we we got along right away and
you know there were there were rules set
up like uh
you know if i had a thought i had to go
to him
with it i couldn't go to the actors
you know that's just chain of command um
of course right and i understood that
and respected that sometimes the actors
didn't understand that
uh uh oh my god i love rachel boston so
much she's she's the lead in the movie
and
um and she's become a very dear friend
and i love her to death
but she almost got me in trouble one day
because
i was outside they were shooting we were
shooting at this country club
um out in like arcadia really fancy
place and
it's sort of the wedding reception
scenes and
so they were in there and it was kind of
a tight room so i
said i'll just i'll just watch it on
video village you know
or whatever and um i'm outside
and so one of the pas comes up and goes
um uh you've been requested on set
so i go oh right flying in right you
know
when your request on say you get there
as fast as you can
and i get there and i go through these
these open doors like this
i come in like this and asha just looks
over me goes what
what do you want and i was like i was
summoned
and rachel's just like oh i'm sorry i
was
i wanted to ask frank a question about
my character and i was like
interesting that's who you ask
ask ask john asher right but i wasn't
saying that to
to embarrass her i was just trying to i
didn't want john to be mad at me
um but it was all good it was fine you
know
yeah um but you know but that's you know
you those are things you have to
understand too if um you know especially
if it's your first movie
you know learn the rules quick know
who everybody is
fast because you don't want to be saying
the wrong thing to the wrong person
right um and that's just that's just
stuff that you learn from
from being on sets and luckily i had
been on sets
in other capacities over the years that
uh so i knew most of those rules already
right and plus this not only did did
um you you know his dad but his dad was
instrumental in
creating this film in some sense because
you stayed and and you remained
doing screenwriting whether you took a
break to do animation whatever
yeah you you felt because of that that
one conversation okay i'm gonna keep
going this guy's not blowing smoke i'm
gonna
stay yeah and and so that was just
it's very interesting yeah no without a
doubt and and
um it was so cool i got to i also i got
to meet on set
on on nighty kids i met um john's
sister rebecca and rebecca
uh is uh elizabeth montgomery's daughter
and she's a really uh she's a terrific
director she directs a lot of
sitcoms um a lot of television work
so she took after her dad also
uh and so i got to tell her the story
too so it was
it was really it was really cool i it
was this was
this was a perfect storm basically for
this film
do you ever think about you know i may
never not that you you won't sell a
script again or have a movie made but
in terms of it being this very special
dynamic that this might have been it's
kind of a one in a million type of
things
yeah i think so i think that um uh
this was a this was a very very special
kind of film even even the actors who
came on board were all
just nobody was no there were no
divas there was no you know ego trip
anything like that
um you know marissa tamay came in on her
first day
and was completely professional
um and it was a joy to listen on my
first day
listening marissa to me reading my
dialogue was pretty cool cool
yeah that would be like yeah that's cool
and she's from
new york as well yeah she's from
brooklyn oh okay yeah but she could
i i'd met her before um through todd um
but she she um when i met her before at
a party she
she uh made fun of me because uh uh
she's
i said i'm from brooklyn i i've lived in
brooklyn she goes oh yeah what part
i said about brooklyn heights and she
goes she goes that's not brooklyn
but um and um tom everett scott was our
lead
and um uh you know that thing you do
like this is like his first movie
working for uh tom hanks
um and he's also um he's become a friend
and
he is he was perfect like
i hear him delivering those lines and
i was like that's that's exactly
exactly what i wanted to hear and so
that was
really cool too and ray seahorn too ray
seahorn from
um better call saul she's the lead on
better call saul sheep
played the sister of rachel boston who's
pregnant
in the movie and um
she actually her delivery was even
better than than the the voice that i
had in my head
you know she's got a great sort of droll
humor um and delivers it with with an
arrow
because she's very doubting of the main
characters and she's sort of almost like
the saboteur
yeah which which created our basically
our kind of subplot
was the two sisters uh one sister trying
to convince the other sister that
he's he's up to something that he's up
to no good because he's he's trying to
keep it all a secret
he doesn't want them to know about his
illustrious past
and what if sort of a ladies man he was
back then
and the fact that he is a kid when he
thinks that you know
that his uh if his fiance doesn't want
children so
this could put a monkey wrench in
everything you know which is why he's
going to these extremes
to try to get this figured out in three
days
um so the subplot is other the two
sisters
uh trying to figure out what's going on
and so they're sneaking into his
apartment and and you know like going
through his stuff to figure out like
what is he up to um and it all it all
works
uh it all it all works as any good
screenplay does where you've got your
your your different plots
that are running
you know perpendicular to each other and
at some point they have to they have to
dovetail in
sure and uh you know
but it took us years to get that right
you know years
i thought something i probably should
say also because it's something that i
think is really important for aspiring
screenwriters which is that
your first draft is nothing more
than you i usually say vomiting up
these ideas that are in your head and
getting them out of your head and onto
paper or onto your
your screen
trying to make a perfect first draft is
a waste of your time
because that's not what first drafts are
for first drafts are
for for my this is my opinion you know
there are other you know
screenwriters who might disagree but but
i think it's just about it's like get it
out
get it out of there because you can't
look at it objectively
unless you can look at it
you know what i mean it's all running
around up in here but unless you get it
out and look
at it and then you can really tell
if something is working or where there
might be a gigantic hole or whatever
the the second draft is way more
important than the first draft
because the second draft is where you
can then
start to chip away or add or
you know like it's almost like if it was
a sculpture
sure are you creating an outline before
you do this messy first draft okay so
it's like you're making this
this bust or whatever you know this like
you know mozart and you're in you're
you're gonna but it's just this lump of
clay or whatever but you kind of know
okay well i know his head's gonna be
here and we're gonna do his vest and all
you know these different things right
you're not just like here let's try this
you have a plan
i yeah i i always have a plan um
i might not the third the third
part i almost said third act and that's
something that i don't
always agree with i don't always agree
with the
first second and third act kind of thing
right it's
i i i think that if you if uh like the
save the cat mentality
um which is that you know everything's
so codified that this has to happen here
and this has to happen here and this has
to happen here
i think that's the danger of that is it
could stifle
imagination um but
when i do an outline um
i don't necessarily fill in that last
part the ending yeah because
i want because so many things can happen
along that road
of getting to that part that
i i like to leave it i mean i've sort of
of course i have some idea of how it's
going to end
but i don't want to i don't want to put
in too many details because i want to
see
if if the ending will find itself almost
organically
and i trust in that it it will it will
find its way as we get closer
so so yes i do have an idea of what that
ending is going to be
um but i don't want it to be
i i don't want it stamped and solid
so yeah i see what you're saying there
so so even though you said
todd had just a rough outline of the of
the first scene or or
first act or whatever for the most part
if you were to do
let's suppose you wrote it from scratch
and and it was just completely your idea
you would have just done
this sort of illustrious bachelor
finally finds the one
and then you know
filling in there's a wedding there's a
kid shows up but then this road trip
movie maybe you wouldn't i and i don't
know how it ends
so you would kind of leave that last
right scene or scenes
yeah and i think that one of the things
i did in particular for
for that script was you know we knew
that they were going to have to
go and visit all these different women
along the road as they get to know each
other and they their develop their their
relationship develops
um so i didn't right away i didn't say
okay
they're going to meet this kind of
person they're that kind of person etc
and
what was really interesting is two
like two or three days before we
started shooting like two or three days
before principal photography
right um it might have been maybe a
little more than that might have been
like a week
but john asher came to me
and he said i need a scene
for marissa where
it ha i want i need her to be a really
strong
woman character because we have a lot of
kind of crazy characters
that that they meet because it's a
comedy all right
um and uh so basically i
i had to come up with a whole new scene
right before we
we made the made the movie and so
you know i think we i don't remember if
we if we added her
if we pulled one that was the one that
was existing
i mean those those women went through
all kinds of changes as we went along
in the original script uh arden marine
who is
just a brilliant comedian um
her character um and in the original
script
was uh the the the stereotypical crazy
cat lady
who they show up at her house and she
has just
dozens of cats everywhere right and
what's wrong with that fabular has a
little tiny dog that is hiding
in his you know in his shirt basically
and
of course at some point the dog jumps
out of his shirt and all the cats go
crazy
and then everything just goes to chaos
it was going to be a very big sort of
slap sticky scene
unfortunately number one
um the budget wouldn't allow
for us to have dozens and dozens of cats
which are
you know the expression herding cats
well that's what you'd be doing
at the time right even if you see if you
use cg to put in a whole bunch of them
it would still i mean it would still be
um not cost effective let's say
um and plus the fact that
uh john asher myself and titus burgess
were
all very allergic to cats so
you know that was going to be a problem
so john asher actually came up with it
with an alternative idea which was
rather than her ha rather than her be a
crazy cat lady that she's just sort of
this crazy mannequin lady
and so we fill her house her house is
filled with all these mannequins who are
all dressed up in clothes
and she refers to them as if they're
real you know real people
oh wow and uh and that ended up working
i don't know i don't say if it was would
work better because we don't know how
the cat scene would have worked out but
but it worked it worked to accomplish
what that scene needed to accomplish
um john came up with a couple of good
ideas that um
uh several in fact that you know some of
them were do
were because of the budget like i you
know when i
when you write a set piece for a scene
you always want to write it big
because it's you know it's usually
easier to cut it down than to build up
right so start big and then go small you
know right
um and so sometimes sometimes you have
to make adjustments just because your
budget is not going to be able to handle
that set piece
and um and john john um is a is a great
director but he's also
he's been in the business his whole life
because of his dad
and so he understands um you know what
is what we're capable of doing with a
certain amount of money and what we're
not capable of doing
so he made adjustments to the script by
the way if something else is you know
the director always gets the final
uh pass on the script um
so so i i might write 12 13
drafts in the end the one that we're
going to shoot is the one that he
does the pass on and that's because he's
the boss
oh sure did you two meet together though
in terms of going over logistics or
different things and he wanted your
input or is that something that's not
necessarily
um we went there was a little bit of
back and forth not much
um where he uh he
sent me he did a pass on it and he sent
it to me
and he asked what i thought and i was
terrified to read it
i was so afraid because i've had movies
made
where the director tossed
my all my dialogue and put in horrible
exposition
you know nightmare dialogue and
i had no control over that you know and
so uh i was
a little nervous even though i i liked
john escher immediately when i met him
and i
had you know faith that he was going to
do a good job
i still he sent me that version i
started reading it i was just
i was really okay here we go
you know but as it turns out that
i would say probably 75 to 80 percent of
the
the script was still mine that he made
changes that he needed to make
um uh and i and i know that i also know
that john
landis and john sat down earlier on
and went without me and went through the
script page by page
line by line and john landis being the
director of some of the greatest
comedies
of all time basically said the ones that
he thought worked and what he thought
didn't work
so it's a team process for sure
did you get to see the final edit before
the premiere
or was that okay so it wasn't like you
were walking into this premiere
no actually it was like again this is
and this is not the norm this is
definitely not the norm but i will i was
invited
to go to the uh the sound mix the final
sound mix
so i got to sit there with with todd and
with john landis and with
john and the producers and they actually
um
asked my input of what i thought and i
john landis laughed because i at one
point
i think todd said frank what do you
think and i said well i said
well i'm the writer as long as i can
hear my dialogue i'm good
[Laughter]
landis landis said i think linda said
yeah spoken like a true writer
what a cool experience fantastic yeah it
sounds like a really like
a dream come true not just just seeing
it kind of come to life
and the different parts but also being
included and that was that's really what
made it
special because like i said i had i've
had other movies made before
you know most of the time it's a set
visit
uh or not at all i mean the second movie
that i had made was
shot entirely in south africa and you
know they don't bring the writer
along to do something like that so um
so this was this was a very unique uh
opportunity
um as a screenwriter um
and and it was nice it was it was very
nice and
um i just i made great friends
um you know with with those people we're
all still in touch
do you believe in screenwriting courses
oh sure
absolutely um um i'm not sure if i
believe in the screenwriting contests
um i've heard stories
some of them are kind of shady um but
um yeah no courses are terrific um
i'm assuming of course that the
instructor is qualified to teach them
um but that's true of any course of
anything
right um i think that
uh you like i said i think i said
earlier that you know
screenwriting is not just about writing
screenplays
it is but it isn't i mean you have to
learn so much more there's so much
there's so much to be learned you can't
just watch movies you can't just read
one book about it
um you know when i first started there
were there were two books that i really
that i really got something at three i
should say three books that i really got
something out of and there's
lots of books out there um and they're
still those books are still out there
um they're probably a little bit dated
books um
uh sid field book called screenplay
which is sort of the
the one that everybody reads um william
goldman's um
adventures in the screen trade is not
really a
a how-to book but it does
explain his process in in a lot of ways
and he also talks about
you know being on the set of movies that
he's written the screen
screenplay for and so forth and that's
that gives some insight into what the
reality is
out there and um the one i think i got
the most
out of was by linda seeger and it was
called making a good script great
and that's where it what i was talking
about before about
your your your second draft is way more
important than your first draft and your
third is probably more important than
the second graph and so forth
uh until you get to the point where
they're just polishes you know or just
touch-ups or whatever um because that's
where you're really gonna be able to
chisel the script to where it's really
supposed to be
um so that that book really definitely
impacted me the most
i think since you you draw
and you write how are the two processes
similar and how are they different
um well they're they're different um
although one of the things that does
have like
yes i get writer's block just like
anybody else does
i can also get drawing block um there
are some days when it's i'm just not
feeling it i can remember when working
at disney
especially when we were in what they
call crunch time which was the last two
months um when we had to get the movie
finished
at least our part of it um the the
animation part done
and you know we're all we're working you
know
seven days a week 16-hour days sometimes
and
uh and you're just you're bleary-eyed
and your hand is cramping up like a
lobster you know and
um every once in a while you'd hear
somebody like we're on cubicles you know
and you'd hear somebody way on the other
side just go like
i can't draw we don't know what that
you're just having one of those days
where no matter what you do you're just
it's not working you know and and
usually that's just because you need a
break
you know um and the same thing the same
thing with
writing same thing with writing you know
there are days
there i write pretty fast which is one
of the things that todd has always
liked about um you know recommending me
or working
you know or hiring me to work on
something is that i tend to work quickly
um and it's because i will
if i get an assignment the way the
most of the time not always but majority
of the time
for the two months the first two months
i will
i won't write a word but that that
those ideas will be marinating up in
here you know
and i'll i'll have it i might get an
idea where i go well i'm going to write
this down
because i like this i don't want to
forget it sometimes
um you know in the in the shower
thinking of something completely
different and
boom oh my god wow that's it that's what
i needed for that scene etc right
and so forth and then in that third
month
i will sit down and i will i'll blast
through it
and write it in sometimes in two weeks
um
i have been known especially toward the
end of the script
i have been known to write 20 pages in a
day
i remember i sent it to john asher and
he went what
he's like no way he's like i'm lucky if
i write three
in a day he said well are there days
when i write three i mean
you have to you have to be in the right
mindset and you have to you know i mean
it takes it's a discipline
certainly um but sometimes you know
it's it's just your head's not going to
be there for it
and that applies to writing or or
drawing doesn't matter
oh wait you know what i just want to say
one word oh sure
um what's really funny is that i find is
that
when i'm writing i always
feel like i want to be drawing and when
i'm drawing i always feel like i want to
be writing
which is i don't know why that is
but uh it's it's really funny it's like
i'll be i'll be
uh like if i if i'm doing a lot of
drawings because i have an event coming
up that i need to have drawings for
you know i'll be like i'm like god i
just want to just want to write a
sketch i just want to write a comedy
sketch or something like that you know i
have to wait till that's done and get to
it but
um but it's it never fails it's always
that way
it's always that way you think we
romanticize
doing something else when we're in when
we see like the the reality of what
something is
that it is very difficult it's not just
the image of it
oh sure yeah no absolutely i mean
um i certainly had a a different
um vision of what
uh animation was before i
actually learned how to do it and then
and then found out oh this is this is
hard this is harder than i thought and
that's
true about screenwriting too i mean you
know i first i thought
screenwriting would be a breeze and and
the the reason i even started writing
was because
um we were making one of those canadian
horror movies
and um it was rock and roll nightmare
and
we we made that movie in like seven days
for you know for for no money at all and
we were all
you know working different jobs and so
forth and
and john fasano who was the writer
director
was overwhelmed because he was
constantly having to answer questions
100 questions
an hour and um there was a scene he
needed a bridge
um and this actually funny this happened
on ihe kids twice
um he realized that there was a hole in
the script that he needed a bridge
between this scene and this scene right
because they could they wouldn't work if
they were next to each other
so he needed just a little scene that's
gonna go plop
right in there right and so um in that
movie
i was playing one of the band members
and and my my
my wife leanne who was not my wife at
the time
was playing my we were playing newlyweds
right
and so the scene was supposed to be late
at night where all these other things
are happening in the house but we're
we're on our honeymoon and we're
supposed to
so it's supposed to be sort of a uh you
know a post love making scene where
we're just lying there we're talking
and john said just just write some
dialogue between you and leanne
so i sat down and i wrote this little
half-page
one-page bit of dialogue
and um john looked at him he was like oh
this is great cool
we'll shoot it right and we shot it and
i and i realized
that as i was writing that scene
i was i was getting bit by the by the
writing bug
because i realized how much i i really
enjoyed it
but again i had not
done my homework at that point like i
was i was just
just utilizing my imagination as best i
could and also knowing i was writing it
for me and i was writing it for someone
i already knew
so uh but i liked it and
um uh to this day i mean
no offense john but um i
it's the best written scene
and but i mean it but that started the
ball rolling for me to say
okay i like that that was fun
i want to do more of that because i mean
as much fun as i was having as an actor
you know you play a role as an actor and
that's really cool and that's really fun
when you're a writer in a way you're
playing all the roles
you know which is what like i said
before about my my acting background has
definitely helped me write dialogue for
my for my screenplays
um but that's fine also that
that kind of thing happens a lot by the
way if you're if you're on set or even
sometimes if you're not on set
you might get a call from the director
saying i need um
i've got a hole here i need it filled i
need a small scene the great part about
being on set was that
um you know john would come to me on set
and say you know
uh i need a scene that we can shoot
tomorrow with
um with ray and and um rachel
uh between the between the two sisters
and it's gonna be in a car
but it needs to bridge this scene in
this scene
right so he goes can you can you give me
something
so i you know i had my laptop on set so
i sat down
and i and i came up with this quick
little scene it was only about
six lines the the best part about it was
though
i was like rachel ray come here
i was like look i just wrote this i want
to hear how it sounds because this is
going to be this is your scene
for tomorrow and so they were able to
read it
right there in front of me and i could
hear if it was working or not
you know so that was that's again that's
a very rare circumstance
sure and we did another one uh later
with um with tom everett scott
and um um uh the actor who was playing
julian who was playing his
um his son or they're just walking down
the street and just a little bit of
conversation a little bit more
of character interaction for them
and like four four or five lines
something like that
but written on set and
basically shot the next day so
unusual but um uh and i'm only unusual
because i
because i was doing it on set i mean i'm
sure it happens where the
the director will call a writer who's
not on set and say i need a scene by
tomorrow i'm sure that happens all the
time
but this this was unique in that regard
what makes a great story
boy that's a that's a good question
what makes a great story is
if it's something that i can't walk away
from
uh that i if if if you've got me because
because i mean there's all kinds of
stories like i'm gonna be specific about
this kind of story you know
um but i know that if if i'm
able to walk a walk away from
from a movie even even just to go you
know
use the restroom or whatever you know go
make a sandwich
and not pause it it means that's the
world we live in now right
it means it means that that story has
has got me
um and i also
i i love dialogue i i just
if and that's the thing i pride myself
the most on
um and i i if dialogue
crackles like a fire i
i love it so much i like i watch a movie
like
lauren's chasm's body heat and the
dialogue in that movie is just
oh my god i just i would love to write
something that good
because it snaps you know it's it's
beautiful
it's beautiful um there's really
interesting there was a movie came out
um i don't know three or four years ago
now i think
um it was um a great movie with kurt
russell
and it was called bone tomahawk and it
was very interesting because it was
actually a horror movie but it was very
cleverly disguised as a
character-driven western right
and the thing that kept me watching it
was
the writer wrote these this incredibly
great dialogue between
all the characters had great dialogue
and that to me
more than the story itself was
propelling everything forward
because i couldn't wait to hear what
they were going to say to each other
next
so those are the things that definitely
you know get my
get my blood pumping right like glenn
glenn gary glenn ross the
dialogue for that is just unbelievable
right
and just just even if this isn't your
type of film but but it keeps you hooked
in each of the characters
and then their agendas whether they're
overt or covert you know and just
the just the dynamics i mean yeah
yeah kaz like lawrence casden um you
know mammoth obviously
um you know some of my friends have been
in movies david mamet movies and i was
just like wow that's
pretty cool you got to do got to read
mammoth dialogue you know
um but uh
that's that's for me that's the biggest
part of it i mean
obviously if a a plot
um is it's so full of holes that you
can't
you know you're like you're almost
laughing at it well that's a big problem
but but i'm i'm i'm i'm more
turned on by by great dialogue than than
more than anything else
well even in in something that's
supposed to be campy or
or you know i mean you were in the um
the black roses and just watching the
the few snippets i mean
there was some great dialogue in that
whether it was like over the top i mean
the things that were coming out of these
characters mouths were it was really
funny
it was like laugh out loud funny so even
though it may be like so over the top
that somebody really wouldn't say that
it worked yeah
and and so that's yeah you know
something else too it's funny
because especially in like horror movies
um if you if you go back to like 1960s
and you look at
uh the the british hammer horror movies
that the movies that would star peter
cushing and christopher lee
um peter cushing
was absolutely brilliant because he
could take
dialogue that on paper must have sounded
ridiculous
like talk just talking about you know
him he's playing dr frankenstein and
he's talking about you know
rejuvenating the soul in a dead body or
something like that or
or he's playing dr van helsing talking
about you know
how sneaky vampires are or whatever you
know what i mean
and peter cushing was the kind of actor
who could take that dialogue
and say it with such conviction
that you totally went with it you didn't
even blink you're just like oh yeah sure
yeah absolutely yeah
you know and that's you know that's when
you're really lucky
when you as a screenwriter if you get an
actor who can do
that you're home free you know
absolutely i was lucky i had
marissa to me and i had you know tom
everett scott and ray seahorn
you know people that could do that you
know
do you use index cards when you're
writing a screenplay no i don't um
i know a lot of people do i've tried
working that way
um and for me it it's just not
i don't know if it's a you know the way
your
left side brain or whatever but i
actually what i always use um they're
actually getting harder to find
those big legal yellow pads
and i just start i just start writing
and i start writing you know
sometimes um i'll get hit with a like
a little just a little snippet of
dialogue
that pops into my head and i'll write it
off to the side but i'll basically go
i'll keep working like this working my
way down
and as i
as i go through it and review it i might
see say oh well you know what
maybe i don't need that or maybe
maybe i should put this earlier and i'll
try to get as much of that as i can
again still leaving that that last
little bit
open-ended right um and
then i will sit down at a so i'll do
that with a pencil by the way
yeah right so then i'll sit down at the
computer
and i'll start writing an official
outline that will
that will actually go scene by scene
i'll always put in
little bits of dialogue that help that
just help with the tone
especially in a comedy um because i
mostly write comedies
that i most should say i'm mostly hired
to write comedies
i like to i like to put in a little bit
of dialogue because sometimes that helps
just establish
for someone else who's going to read it
not for me but for someone else is going
to read that outline
um it will help establish a character's
tone
you know um and and also what the what
the the overall tone of the comedy is
is the comedy slap sticky like faulty
towers
or is it more you know more restrained
um you know you know more like um um
oh i don't know like election a movie
like election
you know um you can help you can help
establish that
by having some of the characters
saved little bits of lines or maybe a
funny gag or something like that or
something that just just
i i like the kind of uh dialogue that
you would see
um in uh uh
like shows like the office and like park
parks and recreation
you know that that kind of banter i like
a lot
i try to you know try to um not
not copy that but try to utilize that
same sort of
um that same sort of tone and that same
sort of snap
sure yeah i was watching master class
and jody foster
gives a great master class and so she
was talking about little man tate
and how they they started you know
fleshing out these characters and
and it was just really fascinating to
hear about you know and you could you
could see
if if you would if you tried the test of
you know covering up the name of the of
the character and seeing you know
diane wiese's character i hope i'm
saying her name right versus jody foster
and then a little what you could tell
just kind of by the the way something
was said
you know jody foster was supposed to be
more working class diane was supposed to
be sort of this you know
a fluent snob that was you know so you
could just kind of see the difference
in who the characters were yeah do you
find that that that is a test for you to
kind of
yeah you know what um that's one thing
that todd was was always good at when we
were
when we were writing together was that i
i mean i
i would sh i would give him a pa
show him the latest pass on it and you
know he would he would
always say like does this line belong to
this character
or or is it someone else that has to say
that should say that line
um for this one of this one of the
couple of scripts that
i'm being hired to write right now um
which i should probably shouldn't even
say the name of it but there are three
lead women characters and they're all um
they're
two of them are elderly and one of them
is is much younger
and originally it was three elderly
women and on the third draft we decided
to make some changes and we made the
one of them much younger right just just
so they weren't all the same because
we were getting into a situation where
it was like who who who's saying that
line
right so that was one way that we solved
that
that issue by by having the one
character drop her down
you know from from being a 60 year old
woman to being
a a 30 year old woman well that
automatically just that change alone is
going to change the dialogue
her dialogue and it's also going to
change the way the other two characters
respond to her
right yeah and there is a generational
tone
to how something is said and i think
there's also an east coast west coast
midwest southwest north i think there's
different
like i noticed people from the east
coast say and so forth and so on
i don't hear that as much from
california natives
and they they might be like yeah and you
know so it just kind of continues or
whatever it's more it's looser
you know but there is you can there's
different uh
just like there's regional accents i
think there's regional
ways of saying something explaining
something yeah and that's uh that's
another thing too is um i i once um was
hired to write
um uh it was a it was a christmas
movie but it was set in um in new
orleans
and um so you know there there's some
interesting accents yeah right
and the character characters obviously
they live there they're going to have
some of those
i'm going to have that accent and one of
the lead characters
was actually a cowboy from texas an old
an older gentleman
so i was now working with those voices
in my head
so speaking we're working with all these
different kinds of
uh of accents now and you know that so
that that and that way believe me it was
very easy to know
which character was saying but um
but yeah i'm um yeah you have to
it's it's if the script is going to work
for someone else
not just yourself for someone else to
read it
it has to be very clear what
what character is saying what sure
sure yeah and i feel like like another
term a stone's throw away
i don't know if i've ever used that term
but i've known people that that they use
that in like
every five minutes or something you know
so it's just there's just certain like
catchphrases and different things
sure um idioms or whatever i don't know
but that people
yeah different areas right and you can
use though you can use those to assign
to a character
that will help establish who that
character is
um i mean certainly they i mean you see
it in
in television series all the time
because they have to constantly do that
because it isn't just a two-hour movie
you know you're talking about episodes
and episodes episodes and
so on and so on you know um my favorite
tv series of all time is faulty towers
the john cleese uh sitcom which only had
12 episodes
but it's to me it's the funniest show
that's ever been made and
if if you look at the scripts
um which they stuck to they'd like to
change a word of those scripts um
you can you can you can know who's
saying what line
very easily because those characters are
so
well defined and um that's
part of what make what makes it so great
who are the protagonists that you love
what do you love to write in terms of
whether it's comedy but what type of
protagonist i
i definitely like
a protagonist who is able to
maintain a sense of humor no matter what
is going on
um i'm i'm a big fan of sarcasm yes
um i know well yeah um if you if you see
i ate kids you will you'll see that
it's it's dripping with sarcasm
um and that's just because i think
i think that comes from the the
influences that i had
growing up at least for comedy um
my my biggest influences were the marx
brothers
um bugs bunny and faulty towers and if
you look at any one of those three
things you will see
even the bugs bunny cartoons there's a
lot of sarcasm going on there
and um so for me that's that's the the
really fun stuff to write
um when a character can just snap back
a a sarcastic line at somebody i just i
i love the process of coming up with
what that
retort is gonna be um that's that's fun
that's the fun part of it all well i
mean that's why taxi and cheers
too absolutely so funny because each one
had their
own sarcastic take on the world you know
whether it was
louis or whatever you know just there
was just
and waiting for that friction to occur
whereas things that were a little more
i don't know if it was a deadpan okay
then
maybe less so when um and i think
sarcasm isn't is an acceptable way of
communicating more on the east coast
maybe i'm wrong well probably okay i
mean
that would make sense since i was raised
there sure sure
yeah and i'm i'm used to that east coast
influence as well and i feel like
people sometimes don't get it when
you're being sarcastic maybe i'm just
not being funny or something but i think
sometimes
sarcasm could be when you're actually
trying to be friendly and it doesn't it
can backfire
yeah so in person it can backfire but in
a script it creates great a great
tension
yeah yeah um and it it it especially
provides the it's an open gate for for
humor
and and that's that's really what i love
the most
is is is writing that line that i know
is going to make todd laugh
okay that's that's your litmus test yeah
it's just todd train a lot i i love it
todd will tell me that he was you know
because todd travels a lot he's a very
busy person with a lot of things going
on and so
sometimes he'll the only time he'll have
to read uh
the latest draft of a script or whatever
is when he's on an airplane flying you
know from the east coast or whatever and
he'll tell me that you know he he'll
call me the next day and say you know
you had me cracking up on this airplane
you know and
then i'm like okay got it
nailed it right that's the true test are
you in a public spot and you can't
contain your laughter
exactly and uh and is everybody staring
at you yeah
how good of an artist do you have to be
to work for disney
and how did you get that good okay
so you have to be
a very very good artist to work for
disney
and that means that you need to have
again done your homework you need to
have
taken classes you know you need to to
they what they want to see from you is
that you can
draw that you can not not just not just
draw cartoons
any you know anybody can do that right
that you can draw
the human figure correctly
that you can push
push that figure like
plus it like so if if if something's
somebody's leaning over that you can
make it enhance it so they're
leaning over because that's part of what
animation is all about right
when i was there um
even though we already had the job had
the job right
everything's going great every day at
lunchtime
maybe it wasn't every day but if at
least a few times a week at lunch time
they had a drawing lab downstairs and
and at lunchtime
instead of going to the cafeteria and
eating your lunch or eating your lunch
at your
in your cubicle you could go down to the
drawing lab
take your lunch if you want and they
would have a model
there sometimes a nude model sometimes
um a model in a
elaborate costume right and
they they had um an instructor there who
was one of the
original story guys from you know um who
worked on
you know movies like peter pan and dumbo
and whatever
who would who would walk around and see
what you're doing and
um walt stanchfield was the instructor
who was there when i was there he's
passed on now but
he well he terrified us because
he would walk around behind us as we'd
have a model and we're
we're working and you know and you you'd
have a time limit
you know you'd have you'd have they they
might do okay these are 10 second
sketches
go 10 seconds boop stop 30 second
sketches one minute sketches and
sometimes it'd be
20 minutes but you're working
and you're working with a charcoal
pencil that you're you know you're
working very quickly and lightly and
so forth gesture drawings he would walk
around behind us
circle around behind us and he had this
big black
magic marker right and if he if he came
up behind you and he saw that you
weren't pushed doing enough of
enhancing it and pushing it he'd go
no no no no you come in with that big
black magic marker and on top of your
drawing you just go like
go like this like the support push you
see in this and that
squash squash you know and and
so the more black marker you had on your
sketch pad
means the more you were not doing what
you were supposed to be doing right
and and you know this was we were
volunteering ourselves to do this and
they encouraged it of course because
you want it especially when you are
when you're when you do i was a cleanup
animator so i'm doing the
the nice really clean finished line that
you see on the on the
screen right working from on the
original animators rough
drawings so but when you're drawing like
that
you can get really tight you know
because you're
very they have to be perfect lines right
so at lunchtime going down there and
then with a with a model
and being really light and loose i'm
going to really loosen you up and
and you know make you relax and bring
your bring your bring your shoulders
from this down to this
um and they're all exercises really but
it's also to keep you keep you sharp
um keep you keep keep
keep in mind that this is why you're
here
not not because you can draw mickey
mouse that's the reason that you're that
you got there
so yeah thinking in a documentary about
charles schultz
i think he talked about like when he was
at his drawing board if i'm
remembering correctly he felt like he
was master of his universe it was just a
really powerful
wonderful feeling for him to just be
there creating and
it was just a place of where he wanted
to keep going back to
yeah is that similar yeah i mean
definitely um
there's a there's a sort of a zen aspect
to it um
when you're when you're when you're in
that zone um
uh you know all of us at disney
in our cubicles had you know we had cd
players and
and you know some of us had little
television sets and and
that were on but they were really more
it was background noise
uh audiobooks we listened to a lot of
audio books
there a long time late at night um and
um but yeah but you need to be but your
focus is here um even if you have a tv
on that's
that's you know watching some great
movie
you know king kong is on you know and is
still
but you still have to stay focused on
this you can hear it
but your eyes are here because your eyes
are telling
you know eyes are going to the brain
brain is telling the hand what to do
so um that part of it and you get you
get used to it
you get very used to it like my wife
still can't understand how
when i'm every once in a while like when
i'm working on on a
on animation these days that i can be
binge watching
narcos at the same time which is
most of the dialogue in in narcos is
subtitled
so she was like how can you do that when
you're done i was like i don't know
i just do it you know the drawings get
done
so but it's i mean it's a it's a
it's an extreme discipline and you know
the more you do it you get more
the more you get used to it i think
you're the first person that we've
talked to who's done animation for
disney we have people
all over the world who watch our channel
who dream of doing the same
i'm wondering if you can share what goes
into making a disney movie like how much
effort
how much of the stuff behind the scenes
do we not see all the little detail and
clearances things oh boy
you know i was a tiny little speck
in a huge process
um the animated movies
i'm not sure how long they take now but
it's probably pretty close to the same
the from beginning to end from from you
know
the start you know script to you know
final final um sound mix or
music mix or whatever i i think as i
recall it was about five years
for one move from one you know feature
animated movie
um i think that's still pretty accurate
it could sometimes be longer if um the
movie is
troubled and sometimes the movie won't
get
basically they'll they'll kill it if
it's taking too long
they might have they might have three
years invested in it and if it's just
not working i mean when john lasseter
was was still at disney he
he i know that he killed a couple of
projects
or at least one that i know of that they
had been working on and working on and
working on they kept trying to fix it
trying to fix it and
in the end it just it obviously wasn't
going to work so it's like
okay we we cut our losses now rather
than continue
um it i don't think that happens often
but it does happen um but you don't
realize i mean
like you know you're starting with the
script
and there's usually research even before
that
so once it's decided that
um you know this is a project that we're
going to do
so for uh for for tarzan
well the first thing that has to happen
is everybody's got to read the books
and then they go and they got to look at
this is all the reference materials i
got to look at all the
johnny weissmiller movies and the you
know gordon scott movies and
and the tv series and comic books and
and all that and and take it all in and
see what
what can you know what what elements
of that character and those um
that that mythos are going to work
within this version which is not going
to be like
all the other versions i mean obviously
there's going to be some similarities
because it's all based on the same
source material but you know what is
what is what is what is disney going to
bring
to that property that makes it special
so there's all that and then once you
know they
then the production designers you know
um
i know for tarzan they took a whole
group of people the producers the
directors the production designers
some of the artists um a lot more i'm
sure
and they all went to africa and they all
went and saw real gorillas
um you know uh in the jungle uh and
spend a lot of time
you know sometimes the artists sketching
them and and just
observing observing them and seeing what
their behavior is like and
uh you know that's all part of the
process too
and then then there's um visual
development or they have you know
uh the uh all these different kinds of
artists come in and do different
different scenes just in uh in their
style
and those and those paintings which are
almost always beautiful
would be would be put up in the halls of
the
that area that quad where they're making
that particular movie
so you're constantly surrounded by the
uh
the the imagery and um and it helps
spark
the imagination and helps you you know
really get an understanding of what
uh what kind of movie you're making
there's all of that then and then you
know when you finally got the script
exactly where you wanted then
you've got it then comes casting then
you're going to bring in your actors
and the actors have to have to record
all of their dialogue
before they can start the animation
because you need the actors
um i need the actors voices
to to be able to animate to so i mean
it's just this process go is a long
process with with
many many many different elements um
and you know uh and you know at disney
of course they have
you know they can have two or three
movies all going at the same time that
might be in different stages
so um uh it was always interesting
it was always something new to see in
the hallways it seemed did you see steve
jobs
yeah oh okay yeah he would have been
third floor we don't
okay all right so i understood he was
traveling back and forth for a little
bit but um
from his from his book yeah anybody
anybody of that
stature would um you might see them
coming in in the
ice in the morning in the hallway but
uh yeah you didn't approach so what um
what would be some of the reasons that a
project you don't have to give specifics
but that it would be
squashed even if you were three years in
if um
uh if if what they would do is
um as they as they move along
in the process especially once that they
have animation to show
um they do uh story reel which basically
would be the entire movie
and either it would be done at like an
animatic where it would be the
storyboards
right and sometimes it wouldn't be the
the real the final actors it would just
be people doing scratch
um what they call scratch voices which
is temporary
voices um in fact my wife leanne does
scratch for them a lot on
on the feature movies um but
um but it would be the entire movie
uh and you would get it so you could get
a sense of
is this story working is it is is the
pace working
is it um are the jokes working
uh et cetera um and so they would have
these things
every every couple of weeks or maybe
once a month or something like that
where everybody sits down in the
auditorium and
we watch all the people that are
qualified to watch it at that point
to see how it's working and everybody
will give notes
and boy sometimes
no matter what you do it's just
it's not hitting
hitting those marks that he needs to hit
to work
um uh home on the range
was the last movie i talked about before
and
and that was a movie that
had a lot of problems we were um uh
it was changing the whole movie was
changing constantly
i mean the basic premise was still there
was about three cows
who were trying to save their their
owner's farm
but the villain changed the the the
motivations
changed every time we went to see it it
was like
almost a whole new movie um and
i i mean i worked on the villain
character in that and
every every time we kept we would
start working on him as looking well i
mean he pretty much looked the same but
the motivations would change for the
character every time we went to another
uh another screening like what i'm just
curious like
i just like why he wanted to to get that
farm like why he needed to get the farm
um and you know they would they would
come up with different
reasons and of course when you change
the motivation
it it affects it's a domino effect to
the rest of the movie
you know any anytime you change anything
it's it's um
it's it's going to impact ev everything
else
so um so that was that was a tough one
that was a real tough one and he did
they didn't kill it they went they going
all the way through and the movie did
come out
but i it's not my favorite by any means
it still
for me doesn't really work so
and it was also the last it was there
was the last one that
they did except for princess and the
frog several years later it was the
it was the last of that era
yeah how did it feel
the last day that you left i mean i'm
just
i did you really have like your stuff in
a box or i mean yeah
well believe me we filled those cubicles
with stuff so it wasn't
it wasn't just a box okay with the
plants right it was a lot of
stuff um because you know especially
when you've been there for for
eight years seven and a half eight years
you know you accumulate things
um so you know because there was enough
warning it was like little by little
take it out so but i think i'm not on
the last my last day
i don't even think i had any work to do
and probably it was mostly cleaned out
so it was basically just probably saying
goodbye
um which was you know it was bittersweet
really because at that point
at that point i think luckily it wasn't
a surprise
we knew it was coming for a long time
and i think i was ready i think i was
like okay i'm ready
to go through the stages of of death
thing right elizabeth
yeah this was finally acceptance sure
right you've been through the anger and
the depression
already that was a long time ago very
similar now they think about it
but i'm sure for some people though
maybe they didn't want to go
it's great when you're at a job and you
don't want to be there anymore and
you're leaving you're like this is great
i could feel the energy pushing me out
the door
but when you don't want to go that's
when it's yeah and
you know i don't think any of us really
wanted to go but when
when it
there was there was no other way you
know
then you had to accept it so i'm sure
you know because
i mean like i said for most of the time
i was there
um that was a great place to work
you hear stories about people
complaining about disney you know doing
this and doing that and everything like
that well
that was not my experience i got to tell
you i loved it
i loved it yeah i mean like any job
there were some days when
especially in crunch time like sure sure
oh god i just
you know only got four hours sleep i
don't want to go back in you know
right or mary in the cubicle a couple
that was on a loud
call to our family or something
i've heard people that absolutely loved
working there and
are still there and yeah especially when
i first got there especially because
i i came in in what and i call the post
lion king boom
because you know these things are
cyclical like there's there's they have
a big hit movie and it does great and
they've got a couple of
successes and then not so much there's
an era where it's
the movies aren't that good and so forth
and
uh hercules we were still riding that
high from from lion king
and um so and um also
jeffrey had started dreamworks down the
street and
he was looking uh to to poach us
um so uh the the
the studio was doing everything they
could to keep us there
so you know throwing money at us
bar parties and gifts and all kinds of
things you know i mean
it was a it was a fun place to work for
for quite a while
um but you know everything changes
things change
um evolution and uh
so i'm just happy that i had the
opportunity to
to work there and you know those movies
that i worked on
are going to be around long after i'm
gone they're still going to be people
watching them
so you know that's nice to know and last
question about disney and that is just
the evolution of the screenwriting
in terms of the emotion that they
started putting in and maybe some of the
topics that they touched on
how did you see that evolve from your
time there well i what i saw
um you know the my first movie was
hercules which was very
funny and slapsticky and and big and
wild and
um and but i saw what they were they
were they were definitely
experimenting with what else they could
do
uh with with the medium um and
and not just you know not just make
movies with princesses and
and heroes and princesses and so forth
um and and i think um
maybe it wasn't a great idea i love i
love atlantis i think
um i didn't i didn't love it by the time
we were
finished working on it because it was a
very very challenging movie to work on
um but uh
since then um it came out on blu-ray i i
watched it again and i was
i really actually liked it a lot but i
can understand how at the time
i don't think audiences were were maybe
ready for that
uh ready for that kind of change in a
disney movie
um i think that they really just um
they they like their little mermaids and
their beauty and the beasts and
you know and uh uh even even i mean even
tarzan i mean
jane isn't a princess but she's still
that kind of
spunky character that um that i think
resonates with audiences yeah so
i saw this quote on someone's blog the
other day and the title was
are stories made or found it's a fine
line between made or found like what
does that really mean but right
um is it something that you see someone
walking down the street
you just envision what their life is
like and you're like i'm going to write
this
or you read an article hear something on
npr and you say i want to
do a fictionalized version of that all
of the above
uh sometimes an idea will come to me
by seeing um a a guest
on on a tv show talking about something
npr's a great source of that kind of
stuff
my leanne is always saying to me oh i
heard this this great interview on npr
you should
make a script about that you know um
one really interesting one um which is
nowadays i just kind of like oh my god
so
the of the two scripts that i that i
originally showed to william asher you
know he's
he's the the one he didn't care for
because it had a
supernatural magic element to it right
that that was
a sort of a modern version of an
old chinese story
that was a children's book that i
remembered reading when i was a kid it
was called the five chinese brothers
and in it these these uh
this one brother gets in trouble with
the emperor and he's sentenced to death
right but the each one of these brothers
has a power has an interesting power so
they're gonna
they're gonna so they and they all look
alike right so
so they're gonna say okay we're gonna
throw you into the ocean so you drown
right but the the one brother has the
ability to to
swallow the entire ocean so he you know
so he doesn't drown and another one
they're gonna feed him to an alligator
or something like that and the brother
has a like a neck that's
like unbreakable and so they keep
switching them out and so that they they
can't kill him right
and um so
in around 19 90
oh maybe earlier than that 80 maybe 88
89 somewhere around there i'm watching
i'm home during the day and i'm watching
the oprah winfrey show
and donald trump was the guest
and at that time they were making him
out to be like he was going to be
this you know this amazing god like
person that he thinks he is now and
he but he sounded legitimate like he
sounded like he was a really
really smart guy and he was really good
at things
and i remember that
oprah asked him uh if he was ever
considered running for office
right and he didn't he was giving a kind
of a vague answer but i just remember
him saying that like
well i tell you this that if i do decide
to to run for office i'll do it
i'll do it full on like i won't you know
i won't hold back
right and i thought to myself
what if this guy knows something that we
don't
like what if this guy can see into the
future right
and then i started thinking about that
chinese
brothers story right and he thought what
if
what if there was these these five
brothers
who were had built up this huge
corporation
because no one else knew that each of
them had a power
and one of them could if he held your
hand he could
read your mind and one of them held your
hand he could see a little bit into your
future
another one could hold your hand and
he could uh heal you
of your whatever your illness is and the
other brother
who was a twin if he held your hand he
could kill you
just by touching you and then there was
a fifth brother and the fifth brother
was the one they were grooming to be a
politician right
so that was the basis of this story that
um
uh that i that was the other script that
i had with return of the gargoyle right
and it was big it was this is like i
said you know everybody's making a
die-hard movie back then because this
the spec script um uh it was through the
roof
they were they were buying up big high
concept scripts all
over the place so so um
it was a huge movie the whole thing like
it's got there's a whole skyscraper on
fire at the end and all this kind of
stuff right
and um uh but that came
from me seeing donald trump on the oprah
winfrey show
um and stuff like that happens all the
time i once witnessed
in a courtroom i saw a guy
try to get out of a a dui
um uh having to pay the fines or
or you know do community service or
anything like that and he
and and he said um he said to the judge
uh well i'm a screenwriter um i could i
could write
a psa about not dr drinking and driving
to um instead of you know instead of
doing that and
and the judge was like no
but i gave the guy credit for trying you
know
but i came that inspired an idea of a
script that i'm working on now
right just that little little moment
that i happen to witness
you never know where it's come comes
from lately
um i i'm now working on the third
um adaption of an existing novel
that i've been hired to write so i i
adapted um the first one was i adapted a
novel that was written by
uh james franco's mom who's an uh uh
she's an author yeah right uh and so
um i was hired to take her novel and
make it into a movie because you know
you can't
you have to make changes you know in
adapting you've got to
sometimes change a lot of things um and
uh the one i'm working on now is a
murder mystery
that is set in the world of magicians
and that also was an existing
material that was a book that was so
when i was hired
um or before i was hired actually my my
manager
um sent me the book and said read this
tell me if you think you can do
something with it
and i read it and i was like i could
definitely do something with this
and so i and so i was hired to to do
that
um so sometimes those things
are brought to me um and sometimes also
you know there's been many times when i
think i might have said before that
um i'll be brought in to a company that
has
an existing material i mean so they call
it script doctoring sometimes
and they really want to make this movie
they love the concept but the script
they have is unfilmable
so i'll have to come in and basically
usually start from scratch usually toss
the existing
material stay with the concept
but make it a movie that that can be
made and make it a make it a script that
can be actually made into a movie
right that that works as a movie
as opposed to um you know i i never even
look who
you know who the person is that wrote
the earlier draft i had one
oh my god this one this was the best
i was brought in for this to this one
project
and uh they said well we're gonna send
you the script
and it's called beware of elevators
right so now title of the movie is
is beware of elevators what kind of
movie do you think that would be
oh well maybe some people will be stuck
in a high-rise elevator
right so like a drama sure you know
maybe a horror movie
right that's what i was thinking too
right maybe the elevator has a mind of
its own
yeah right so that's what i'm expecting
i get the script and i start to read it
and i realized about 10 pages in
that this is a movie about a guy
who dies in an elevator and he comes
back
as his fiancee's dog
and the movie is the guy trapped in the
dog's body and we're hearing his
thoughts
and everything as he's now trying to uh
basically protect his his fiancee and
help her get over the grief and
everything like that right
well it was it was
just terrible it was a terrible script
right
and i fir i was gonna pass on it i was
gonna say no i just doesn't i'm not
gonna do a talking dog movie
sorry but then right before then i just
had a thought and i and and i thought
what what can i what how could i
possibly make this work
and what i ended up doing was turning it
into a mystery because in the original
script you
you you you find out how the guy dies
right away right
so that's he died an elevator
right so what i did was have
the the eye comes back as a dog doesn't
doesn't remember why how he died
and so over the course of the
the script he start he little by little
he starts getting flashes of what
happened
that night and the further along
the more flashes he gets he more he
starts to put it together as to what
happened
and so it became more than just a comedy
about a
a guy trapped in a dog's body it also
became
sort of a mystery because we're finding
out it's unfolding you know it's like
peeling an onion you're finding out
little by little what
led to that and how and why did he end
up here in this dog's body
and then it worked and i i ended up
i ended up loving that script it's like
one i really love it'll probably never
get made
but you know that's that's how it goes i
mean i still got paid
so that you know that's so funny that's
a that's a big misconception also
about screenwriters okay people
a lot of people think that um working
screenwriters
what we do we write a script and then it
gets made
and then we go in the next script and it
gets made and you know the next graph
you get made
i would say
five percent of the scripts that i get
hired to write get made
five percent but i'm still a working
screenwriter
uh you get hired you write a script
you know um you get paid a certain
amount for that
for that script right and then that
script
may never get made i wrote a script for
for um
jlo for jennifer lopez that
i was like oh this got this has to get
made it's for jennifer lopez right
nope did like 12 drafts on it no got
paid
but that that movie will never get made
um
it's when you get a movie made
that's great that's that's a big deal
but
yeah the rest of the time you're you're
still working
you're still creating you're still you
know if you're lucky and you're getting
hired um
and uh and also you know then there's
the matter of
coverage coverage is a big deal in this
in this business so coverage is when
the you write a script and the producer
sends it to a um a script reading
uh company right there are several of
them here in
in la um and
what they do is they have somebody break
read the script break it down
and then in the end there are there's
three possibilities that they assign to
it one
is pass which means
no we're not interested one is consider
right which is maybe if you know you
work
on it it might might have potential and
then
the holy grail recommend right
now something like 90
of the scripts that these companies get
get pass maybe
you know eight eight percent or so
nine percent get consider
and there's variations of consider
there's like consider with
you know considerations and so forth
right but
it's still in the consider this is this
is pass
this is considered one percent
of the scripts that that go through
these companies get recommend
so that's what you're up against you
know and you know
if when you get that if you if you get
that recommend
that's a big deal that's a huge deal
yeah
what's the name of the check that you
get if if um
it actually call it first day of
principle yeah
because that's that's normally that's
when you'd get
the money uh the rest of the the big
money
for for that you would get for for
writing the screenplay
yeah so a big majority of what you do
is writing something doing many drafts
getting paid that initial chunk
but most of the time something's not
going to be
it's not going to go to production and
you won't get the
remainder of it you know but
keeping working is uh
you stay focused on it um luckily
you know sometimes those scripts are
great just because they don't get made
it doesn't mean they aren't good and you
can use them as
um as writing samples to show that
you're
you know you know you're not you're not
you're not counting on like i i
don't show anybody return of the
gargoyle anymore because
it's dated and it's from you know from
the early 90s or whatever
and and so i i'll i can show them
something that i've written in the last
couple of years
that uh is um maybe it didn't get made
but it's still
it's still i think it's a terrific
script or someone else thinks it's a
terrific script
um and that will um sometimes the um the
person
who's looking for a screenwriter might
read that and go oh i like i like the
attitude you had with this
so um yeah we're going to hire you you
know and
and and in the end best case scenario is
of course your movie gets made
but um but yeah i mean working
screenwriters
are not putting out a movie uh you know
every year
we might write three scripts in a year
but uh
um cause it's really hard to get a movie
made it's really hard
anybody will tell you that in this
business it's tough
and with i hate kids there was already
financing attached right because todd
had his production company
uh well todd found an investor oh he
didn't okay
a couple of them really but we needed
you need one to get you started you need
one
you know that's going to put in a good
chunk of that budget so that
other investors will go oh all right
well somebody else has put money into it
um what happens all the time is you know
a movie starts to go into production
and you've got um uh you've got a budget
and you're but you need some other
investors
you get somebody some people interested
but then your first investor drops out
and then that's that's a house of cards
that's just gonna gonna fall
uh todd and i had a movie uh
well it was a while back now um uh
another comedy we had written
that um we were in
uh we were in pre-production we had we
had the office open we were scouting
locations we were casting
everything like that everything was
going swimmingly and
um the investors had a clause in their
contract that said that they could
approve or disapprove
the three leads that killed us because
they wanted reece witherspoon and we
tried to
explain to them you know reece
witherspoon gets
you know our budget was like three and a
half million dollars right
our reese witherspoon gets more than
that for a comedy
right alone that's that's the whole
budget right there right
i mean she might do like a little art
house kind of
you know oscar potential role for
for less money but for a comedy no she's
good
that's our whole budget right there so
they oh they want anna ferris well anna
ferris is the same deal you know
and we we struggled and struggled and
struggled to find something they would
approve
um if i remember correctly todd could
tell me if i'm
remembering this right or not but i zyra
caulk read the script and liked it
and was ready to say yes and they they
said no to her oh really
so wow so go figure right so um
that really we ran out of time to make
that movie basically we had to shut down
um it's too bad because that was a very
very fun script
i i still love to see that movie get
made yeah right
i know yeah she's done a lot of great
she's done a lot of great stuff
yeah yeah yeah i got it so excited i was
like oh that would be awesome that would
be super cool
and then a couple days later like i
called the i called the office
the production office and the guy was
like now we're shutting down i was like
oh
god wow yeah so and i actually i
actually quit
a job because because we were in
pre-production which goes to show you
nothing nothing's in stone until it is
yeah
no why is there such a backlash
toward working screenwriters from
screenwriters who have either never sold
something or maybe just told one thing
and there's like this misconception of
success yeah i think that
part of that probably comes from you
know now we have the imdb
and and you know your credits get get
posted there but the only
credits that get posted are the movies
that get made right
so you don't see the the 10 other movies
that uh you know the the writer was
hired to do
that you know may have gone as far along
as as the movie i was talking about a
few minutes ago about what that todd and
i did
where we got all the way into
pre-production and then
you know it got shut down um
sometimes sometimes the producers just
lose interest in the project
um and so there's all kinds of reasons
why the movies don't get made
but i i think that um especially
writers who are new to the business or
trying to break in or something like
that
um they can look at um uh at somebody
who's written a
screenplay book and say well he only
made one movie
i mean i know that the save the cat guy
i'm not a big fan of that book but
you know he had written one big movie
which was
um a blank check i think it was called
or something like that
and um and then he wrote this this book
about screenwriting that a lot of people
bought and a lot of people were saying
yeah it was like so this guy wrote
you know all these books and he only
only wrote one movie well no he didn't
write one movie
he wrote lots of movies it just happens
that
that particular movie is the one that
got made you know
i mean i could easily write a book about
screenwriting and they would look at my
resume and go oh you know you only had
you know one movie made in the last 10
years you know and
and they'd be right according to imdb
but they wouldn't see i'm happy to
parade out all the checks that i've
gotten
from other from other producers and
other projects you know what i mean
um and you know look
i i was there once too absolutely i'm
i'm
it's before before you really understand
what this business is
there's a lot to this business that you
don't see
that you don't know until you are in it
because you're basing your you have
preconceived notions of what this
business is based on what you've seen on
television what you've seen in
in movies about movies um and
uh sometimes sometimes it's true
a lot of the times it's not and that and
that goes back to
way back to when you know making movies
about movies from in the
1930s and 40s you know that was never
accurate
um sunset boulevard yeah yeah
my god i mean um the james cagney movie
man of a thousand faces which was a
biography of
of lon chaney the silent film actor um
it's all baloney i mean there's so much
in that movie that is
not true about movies is not true about
lon chaney
you know what i mean but i believed it
when i watched that movie
you know when i saw it when i was
younger i was like ah that's that's how
it happens and how it works
you know that's like i said before
that's where you know you're walking on
the set and
the the shining armor's going this way
and the bunny
the guy in the bunny costume is going
this way the chorus girl's going that
way
what about trumbo sorry to interrupt but
what about even though
they did their research they did okay i
mean there's always going to
a screenwriter has to adapt
the story to a certain degree now it's
up to the screenwriter and the producers
how
close to the truth they want to stay
these days
it's you're the closer to the truth the
better because you're going to get
ripped to shreds
you know back then nobody really cared
you know
um but um and now and now there's a lot
more research available too
that is not just to the screenwriter
who's writing the script to the people
who are going to see the movie
and they're going to go oh let me find
out about this guy and
so you know it's just like adapting a
novel
you know you you you are right you're
making a movie
this is the movie this is not real life
you know i'm sure argo um the movie that
that
um ben made is
there's there's a lot that's not true
about that story the story is true
but you're but movies are entertainment
i mean you could learn something from
them hopefully
at times but you're you're not
you're not telling the reality that can
be a documentary and even those
sometimes are
twisted to documentaries are making
somebody
understand somebody's point of view
about a story right
but um you know this is the job to make
an uh something that entertains
whether it whether it makes you laugh
makes you cry
scares you to death you know just makes
you feel good whatever it is
and that's the job and so
that would bend the truth from time to
time
so the reality for a working
screenwriter is
you may be hired to write something you
may spend
months on something multiple drafts you
just get that one
payment for completing the manuscript
but then or for the actual script but
then well it's usually several
payments but oh it's okay so it's
several payments and it's okay they give
you
for the first draft and revisions so
it's usually broken down like that yeah
okay
interesting so you get the series of
checks or whatever
with the promise that maybe more will
come if it's made and then it's never
made it's not on your imdb
so it'll be in it'll be in in the
contract that it'll say that
the um the the full amount based
on the on the uh the total budget
uh will be paid um it will be this
amount
based on this budget uh and will be paid
no
no later than um first day of principle
photography
so that's why that's why we like the
first date
first day of principal check it's very
nice to get
sure but then continuing on knowing that
that could be a reality
yeah and that you won't always i know
you said with i hate kids it sounds like
just a magical
experience all in all and so many
different parts of it yeah
and it may never mimic that for a lot of
people but
yeah warm embracing and look
serendipitous
i i i consider this this
this crazy business which i love
it's a house it's always a house of
cards
you can never tell when
one little dink a little card at the
bottom of that thing is gonna
be pulled out and then the whole thing
comes crashing down uh it happens
all the time so i always say
you know look nothing nothing is real
until it is and that means going right
up to
you can even be shooting a movie and it
can be shut down
so uh you know it's it's a it's a
crazy crazy business and i love every
minute of
it maintain
what it is that the author was really
trying to do with the story
like what what what he or she is trying
to say
in the overall and try to stay true to
the
to the basic beats of the story if you
can sometimes you can't
um try to keep your characters true to
the characters
as they were defined in the story but
the trickiest part i've found
i said i've done three of them now is
when i when a story
is written in the first person
meaning that you are you're reading
that that person's thoughts right as
that person is
interacting with other people and like
in a state in a stephen king novel
you know like pet cemetery or the
shining you're
you're hearing uh you know jack's
thoughts as he's as his mind is
deteriorating
right so then the trick becomes now
you're going to turn that into a movie
how do you get that information
out without having to do like a voice
over
like thinking kind of thing which nobody
likes
unless you're doing something like film
noir kind of narration
right um you have to find
new and clever ways to get that
information
to the audience without it being too
expositional without it um uh
you know like i said without having a
narration
you have to find more clever you have to
be clever about it you have to find a
way to say how am i going to get these
thoughts out there
so that it tells the story without it
being
distracting so
there was a lot of that in uh the last
the last book i wrote uh the last book i
adapted
um there was a lot of that in in betsy
franco's uh book so
um so that's that's the big challenge
there
and i've actually come to really enjoy
that challenge
you know it was a little intimidating at
first when the first one i did but
now that i've done three of them i'm
kind of i kind of
get it and i kind of dig it and i i'm
not afraid of it
how common is it for the actual author
of the
book to want you to adapt it rather than
someone else saying i really like this
story let's try to get the rights to it
and
like which way happens more the actual
author of the book seeking adaptation or
you know usually the um uh the author of
the book
will be offered an option
uh for a certain amount of time um
well kind of like the studios do the
studios
you know op will option a script for you
know for two years or three years or
something like that
in which case they pay they pay the the
writer
uh a certain amount of money that
will let them develop the project and
potentially make the project
in that time period and if they don't
make that movie
in that time period uh they put it
in what they call turn around which
means that they say
you know what we decided we're not gonna
make this movie so we're giving the
rights back to you
you know and you get to keep the option
money you don't have to give that back
but but they're basically saying you
know no we decided to move on
et cetera um todd and i had that happen
uh with um with woodstock
wood stuck it's called um is it about
woodstock yes
oh okay interesting it's a comedy about
what and um so
uh 20th century fox optioned it um
and they optioned it for like i think it
was a year and a half or something like
that to develop it and they they were
trying to develop
it and develop it and i think robert
duvall was
attached at one point very briefly and
um but eventually um i partly i think
because it was a period piece and which
were
expensive this is this is before cg was
available
um so it was quite a few years ago um
so eventually um they they put it and
turn around
they gave the rights back and um and
which you know
means that we could still bring that
that uh property to another studio
uh and and have them option it and
possibly make it
but will it happen probably not you know
especially if it's a script that's been
around for a long time it's it's a
little harder
um but the difference is now that
it would be a lot easier to make that
movie now than
then because because it's a period piece
and it took place
and that the most of the movie takes
place at the woodstock festival
well back then before cg if you were
gonna make that movie
first of all you need you know a hundred
picture cars from 1969
you need thousands of extras stretched
out over a huge
area uh to replicate the
uh you know the the hippies you know and
everybody
and then you need the stages with the
bands right and you need
to pay for the music because it has to
be the music from the festival right
so that was an expensive endeavor no
doubt
and i think that's part of the reason
they eventually turn put it in turn
around
nowadays would be a lot easier because
with cg you don't need
100 picture cars you need 10 and then
the rest of them you fill in with cg
have them go back for miles and miles
and miles same thing with the crowds
you have your hero hippies in the front
and then you fill in the rest with with
cg characters because you can't tell
that they're
real or not that janice joplin look like
exactly
yeah i mean that and you need to know
what about her music well i'm not even
sure
music would still be expensive yeah
that's for sure
but um and even if you did replicas of
the music you still have to pay for the
rights so you might as well get the real
thing
right um but um and and the music is
such an important part
of the story um in fact we we utilized
the music
um to actually represent
what was happening but in the dynamic
between the family that were
stuck there so they they were stuck
there oh it's stuck
so um um great script i got a lot of
work
because of that script again it was one
of the one of the ones that
people read as a sample and we're like
oh you're hired that's great you know
um so was it like a conservative family
yeah oh okay
so when his 16 year old daughter runs
off into the into the festival to look
for her boyfriend
he has to go after her so for him it's
like
going into enemy territory right so
there was a lot
of great potential for humor there um
but um but then ang lee made a movie
about
woodstock like i don't know eight or
nine years ago
um that did not do well so we were like
well we can't show it to anybody
right now because everyone was like well
his movie did failed miserably so
which i i'm not even sure if it failed
miserably but it did not
do you know big numbers so
so but you know these this is what
happens this is
this is what it's like well and and you
know thankfully
my uh my lovely wife leanne has been
very patient with me and
uh has um and she she's a
producer at disney now so she's doing
fine but
she's always been um very um
willing to let me pursue what i needed
to pursue which is
which is great so she's awesome nice
that sounds really funny yeah a retired
currently
we love that script todd and i always
talk about we'd love to be able to you
know dust it off and put it out there
again
and and you just gotta wait for the
timing to be right
you know what i mean you know also you
know when you put a script out
every it goes out to everybody right for
the most part
so everyone's reading we had we had uh
wood woodstock was at caa and it went
out uh you know
like with with a bunch of other scripts
on the same day and and we were we were
um
uh what do you call it um
um i'm forgetting the word but like we
it was showing that we were doing really
well like we were we were expected to be
the highest one
that week and and that's not what
happened
it it didn't uh nobody bought it
and and then it sat around for like for
like two years before
20th century fox um found
a copy of it or was sent a copy or
something and
and they read it and they said oh we
well we like it so we'll take it
and they must have passed the first time
around but but then you know you have
turnover at the studios where
so the the executives who were there two
years ago
uh are not there anymore and there's new
guys in and maybe they haven't read that
script so
uh you know sometimes that's why some
that's why a movie you know um
like forrest gump sometimes takes
years and years and years and years to
get made
it's because you got to have you've got
to find the right person has to read it
at the right time
is that what happened eric roth shopped
it around for years oh yeah from what i
understand i don't know
the exact details of it but it's kind of
famously known that the
the movie was uh it was out there
years before and had been read all over
town
and and you know finally um it just took
the right
um robert zemeckis and whoever else to
to champion it wow who'da thought yeah i
know
so i always keep faith that uh possibly
some of those earlier scripts that we
really loved so much
might still get made someday probably
not
but it's possible that's true yeah
could king kong have been written today
and have been successful
i know you did a documentary um called
long live the king yeah long live the
king with uh trish geiger
2016 but could that character have been
effective
if it had been written today
i yes because i think that is a
character
that there's a there's there's so many
different levels of that character
there's so many different sort of
classic
tropes in that character it's so many
different things
he's the the king who falls from grace
he's
he's the fish out of water when he gets
to new york it's
it's unrequited love i mean all of those
things are all part of king kong
and uh you know the original movie
was as an epic film because
the fact that movies weren't even around
that long
when it came out and it's this massive
incredible feast for the eyes and the
ears and
uh and dinosaurs and and you know and
fey ray who's
beautiful whose daughter i'm going to
meet tomorrow night nice um
and um
it's a timeless story now you know peter
jackson had his version come out in 2005
and it was met with
some people love it and some people hate
it most of the people that hate it
hate it because of their love for the
original movie and that nothing's ever
going to compare to that and actually
peter
even agrees with that but you know he
was
he was doing his version of it um
and i happen myself i happen to like it
um it's just a little long
it's a little long um but but i think
that there's so
many um there's so many things about
that story and about that character
that resonate with people one way or
another
and so i think that no matter when it
would have been made
as long as it was made well
it would resonate with that era without
a doubt